le monde salue très contente de vous
rencontrer
alors vlad tu me disais juste en jeu
l'an ce que tu me vois pas à l'écran
c'est normal on va pas vraiment se voir
parce que parce que on fait plein de
trucs en même temps et donc peut pas
tout ouvrir mais nous on te voit enfin
il te vois d'accord dommage quand meme
web ont même évoqué il faut que tu
viennes à cannes pour me voir qui est
bientôt
bon donc ça va commencer déjà horrible
suis assez surpris d'ailleurs
d'apprendre que gris choc mais comme
quoi mais pas actif donc les palais en
cours sur l'internet
attends je vais te dire même si je le
vois sur la caméra il est il est devant
son écran il est assis devant son écran
et son visage est très blanc d'ailleurs
king tut peu moins de voyez le lien sur
le plus chez to play oui je peux envoyer
ça a alors attends je vais t'envoyer ça
via facebook
tac tu veux le lien du live où tu veux
le lien du du chat ou les deux du
théâtre
sinon je suis connecté sur facebook
alors le lien du chat je vais t'envoyer
ça à tout n'est pas si facile tout ne
tient qu'un autre style blad tu te
rappelles exact que j'ai beaucoup de
fenêtres ouvertes
mais ok j'ai réussi à faire cet exploit
et je vais danser aussi le chronomètre
tous les gens qui te salue d'ailleurs
dans le chat et ils te disent enfin un
micro de qualité
ça fait la différence un nouveau micro
vlad oui quand quelqu'un après vieilli
ramallah prix payés a bola prêta
finalement oui ça le [ __ ] alors c'est
parti mon blad c'est parti ça y est moi
oui
ah bon écho c'est ça leur nom plutôt
espagnol je prévois berlin tu prévois où
tu sais je sème ok calibre de deux des
six enfants comment les petits dossards
des coûts très très trick est en fait là
ils ont rentré dans une très très grande
ligne qui n'est plus à la mode des 4l le
coût principal maintenant fabrice tourre
en rouge et 4 h 3o faucheux 4h trois
fois 5 d'embouts 3 ça a été jouée par un
ouvrier le compteur sacha à paris on a
brûlé l'aijep de temps à loulou vent
enfin bruxelles a donc sa charge aux
assises se fout de trois quarts et
l'esthétisme cavale et c6 est plus fort
donc ce que lui un joueur oui j'ai
regardé et c'est peut-être un des
meilleurs spécialistes mondiaux dans
cette position là maintenant oui mais le
problème se souvenir de ce que je
regarde
il est facile d'être spécialiste mais il
est beaucoup plus dur d'être humoriste
nantais des spécialistes mais pas un
humoriste justement avant d'ailleurs
c'était le contraire en tant que injures
de chèques j'étais plutôt me morice qui
au spécialiste marseillais revient donc
est ce que tu peux en fait on a une
théorie sur le tchat avec les gens et
les abonnés c'est qu'en fait les grands
maîtres ce ne sont que des grands
maîtres de mémoire j'ai bien sûr ça joue
un rôle en rôle très important mais je
peux vous citer pour un des noms de
joueurs de chez qui ont une mémoire
horrible je cite pas taris et n'a pas
fait une mauvaise mémoire vous fera
peut-être avec cet exemple pour le moins
il ya une mort horrible juste bon logo
est vrai que ces deux là je les donne le
plus frappant mêmes écarts peuvent c'est
très frappant dans le sens où c'est un
des tout meilleurs
enfin il était champion du monde le mec
moi
c'est pas obligatoire d'ailleurs si vous
suivez la partie fabrice bosset dans ces
six si je pense que l'un des bons coups
durs cette cause
bizarrement parce qu'on prépare d'abord
8 de doubler le doublage des deux tours
donc on joue avec un pion de moi mais on
veut contre attaquer le centre de 4 et
des quatre aller récupérer si on joue
bien on doit les récupérer cette fois je
pense que de recettes est un bon coup ok
il ya un autre coup - comme fois sans
cautionner ce pas parce que en menace
d'être désagréable comme par exemple
prendre leurs fosses trois fois sans que
je pense que c'est un bon coup pratique
dure c'est peut-être le plus en forme
web
de toute manière je dois dire que je me
souviens de rien juste l'évolution de la
pauvre est ce que tu penses legris cube
se souvient annoncé sur c'est sûr que
même avec ses habitudes là il leur est
pas perdu autant de temps quand même
pour faire tous ses couleurs mais tour
des huit ok peut-être maintenant faut se
souvenir qu'il a voulu prix départ forcé
b3 ou aux bons les uns juste fait un
cours de pratique en fait mais je vois
aucun problème avec moi sans que je ne
sais pas pourquoi elle réfléchit au
temple x 5 parce que c'est les banques
qui doivent répondre aux questions à fin
mai
pâques est heureux c'est peut-être cru 6
me c'est dommage qu'ils recommencent
avec c'est sale habitude de dépenser
tout son temps dès le début du match on
oui c'est dommage mais peut-être karaoké
il veut active au max son cerveau pour
pouvoir jouer le plus possible pour donc
de mener plus tard d'ailleurs je pense
que peut-être deux sens que cinq
cavaliers qatar est aussi intéressant
une fois lu puis on paie à bouger parce
que après les noirs vont bouger
comprendre que le 4 2 dames quatre
fosses trois fous de 4 et en attaque pas
que le pion au no 5 mais aussi la torah
wii ware je pense que de cinq ans
maintenant est tout à fait justifiée -
ok j'ai proposé quatre coups il choisit
l'un des coups que je viens de citer
mais on comprend pourquoi tuer son
entraîneur gratuit tu vois les coûts
beaucoup plus vite
oui je pense qu'il y avait eu en film
american lung qui a murmuré dans les
oreilles des chevaux oui je les previews
payeurs mais il est vrai que le film on
y parle un peu de bois
est ce que tu as vu le film s'appelle et
any given
sunday sur le caillou sans aucun doute
mais je les je me mets il faut il faut
absolument que tu le vois pas ce que ça
parle un peu de ton boulot avec plus ou
moins de tous que mentalist comme on dit
par mais c'est marrant toi qui un tel
cinéphiles que tu t'es pas vu ce film
ok mais c'est normal et gagnent et en
plus cette dernière permet à je suis
plutôt sur les kerry était série
télévisée que là on en parlera on en
parlera un peu plus tard des séries télé
vlad on regarde le singe sous le coude
ok maintenant donc justement à l'une des
idées est réalisé donc pour il va pas
prendre cher parce que roulers ans
qu'elle voit un terme at il voit
sûrement prendre damas trois faux des
quatre tours bord après quoi je pense
que c'est tout à fait bien pour les
noirs d'ailleurs je préfère le noir avec
dams et ours et oui tu as donc
s'annoncer résultats parfois de
réfléchir à ces beaucoup de l'ouverture
de maintenance a lieu parfois ça n'a eu
d'autre résultat malade n'est ce pas
parce que roque et comme l'e3 sega lui
si bien sûr ok malgré les faux blessures
des catérogies segal bien qu'on va lire
trois que valeo 4 et tout ce que tu veux
oui bien sûr comme le cadre de trois
jeux président moïse est peut-être
pourquoi pas d'un mot 7
je préfère toujours un petit peu le noir
mais je pense que ces gars maçanet mieux
à condition des quatre noms puisque tu
as le mauvais fulham ou au terme des 5
j'ai pas trop aimé gérer fait davos est
plutôt sain je vois hauteur de 2,5 à
cause de foot de tuteurs je vois pas
quelque chose mon dessin que je parle
pas trop mais ça fait disjoncter je
crois pas que ça change l'évolution de
la pause ce que la roque et les noirs
bulle de jouer quelque chose comme 5
sans trop se poser de questions que
quand même avec de telles pièces actif
le piano seul et c'est
et rien de grave mais en plus c'est un
pion passé isoler s'est passé et
n'oublions pas entendre qu'ils ont un
grand joueur
sacha elle a commencé avec un jouet de
t'arracher et donc les plus isolées où
est donc faux 3 d'ailleurs c'est un bon
réflexe
je pense qu'un bon réflexe là maintenant
qu'est-ce que je le ferai peut-être tour
eu ces 6 outre ses six plus tôt mais tu
sais j'ai l'impression que son avantage
c'est quand même un peu évaporée dans le
sens où avant ils étaient juste milieu
dans une position tranquille et là ça
peut tourner donc déjà je pense que des
cinq ça a été une faute et pas tout
simplement parce qu avec les blessures
ce set et les diagonales ouverte pour
fouler fund iv c'est devenu plus facile
de jouer avec les doigts
avant peut-être sat est plus facile de
jouer avec noah moi je pense toujours
que c'est une position légale malgré
tout disons que la bonne foi nous
maintenant par exemple c'est de mettre
le cavalier sur 6 pour se battre pour
les cases des cas très juste
damas 3 bien joué leur montage je suis
enceinte
au point qu'elle réussisse et maintenant
donc ok il veut quand même faire cavaler
e6 au prochain coup si oui ok kovalev 5e
toujours très très très dangereux dans
cette cadence d'accord dévoilé 5e
toujours si tu veux être en demies
avantage pour souhaiter à titre qu'ils
quittaient le cavaliere donc ça a été le
séquence du coup moi le jeu par sa
charge
tu sais comment on appelle ce genre de
pièce un wlan ici on les appelle les
blattes de la position mais moi je suis
là de quoi nantes watts et vlad tout
court cauvin et quant à une pièce pour
hisser des caves de la position si
jamais un fou qui pue derrière des pions
au kwat à des quêtes quoi donc là il a
réussi à placer un plat dans f5
c'est dangereux quoi
voilà donc il commence à faire les
concessions pour rendre son joug plus
facile parce qu'il est vraiment mon mal
de temps donc pas très bien comme le
début donc qu'est ce qu'il veut il veut
dans baissier sa boîte pour 2,5 tous
deux autour de 5 e tour si d'autres
titres juste pour rendre son jour plus
facile moins bien sûr objectivement
lampions simple ou quoi ok mais il est
très bon final peut-être la tenir quand
un malade il peut peut-être aller tenir
me semble au futur c'est pas la bonne
tendance déjà six touchés 2 peut-être
d'alger 3 avec les deux réussissent
peut-être un faut bouffer à l'heureux
dame au 3 mai que voler ou 3 permet aux
normands de stabiliser les positions
donc acquis et les blancs sont nettement
améliorées voir gagnant quoi moi il faut
montrer les types oui oui oui comble au
début du match c'est que malheureusement
été plus ou moins prévisible parce que
c'est souvent le cas quoi dur sans
peut-être elle va répéter les contours
d'un petit rouage de roche 2 ac as we à
4 bois et les noirs n'ont pas de les
casser dos et ça c'est horrible
ok bien sûr les pauses gagnante mais
parfois il est pas si facile de gagner
ça elle vous contre le cavalier et la
turquie qui commence à faire les qui
commence à créer des cd de perpétuelles
de père peut-être parfois dans batman
d'inscrits a été malheureusement parce
que la tour est très très bien passé sur
la 5e par exemple les taux permet pas au
bras de fer ne pas au noir de jeu h 4 h
5 h 30
enfin ce foutu quoi ok ok + ou - abandon
ok peut-être prendre ces quatre fers
tour s'est vite sac fait la tour est ok
mais c'est les techniques du peloton
soit manger fait nul contre un grand m
ire dans cette finale américaine avec
lecavalier
ah oui bien sûr le problème pour les
banques notaires si les noirs arrivent à
faire h 5 h qatar mais n'ont pas réussi
donc maintenant ok comment il dit la vie
à 12h11 pour le noir ou à 3,4
enfin un moment donné le roi va venir
sur rue69 établissements maintenant
trois ou quatre ans quatre enfants
toutes les voies ramène aux roues oui
oui c'est une belle ville d'ailleurs
donc pourquoi pas y aller coiffer nous
mais paraît-il d'après ton facebook qui
au syndrome oc aussi pour moi mais c'est
très bien sans un mot mais tu connais
nom soit raymond ok y'a pas un seul
russe qui connaît pas cette vie là parce
que critiqués y avait le festival
musical très populaire chez les soviets
mais jamais été à mes tient du coup du
contenu viendra me voir en cette année
on pourra aller passer une après midi ça
nous fera des vacances
c'est pas difficile d'y aller en train
on pourra aller passer un petit moment
ok ok 1 0 mal mal non plus la manière
était pas n'est pas très convaincante
ouais bon ok greffe et d'ailleurs je
sais ce qu'ils voient à être jouée par
des chocs on va voir qu'est-ce qui
viendra répondre
donc oui je rappelle pour tous les gens
qui sont dans le chat en fait bladé
l'entraîneur pour parler comme on l'a
des des gens qui suivent et qui sont pas
forcément spécialisé échec tel
entraîneur de gris tchouk on peut dire
ça comme ça
et pour être plus précis et à prendre ça
comme se doit a été rappelé et content
tu le seconde parce que normalement les
entraîneurs implique
l'émotion qui au souhait qui entraînait
les conquois plus fort que son pull oui
là c'est pas le cas donc je suis
cependant je suis là pour l'aider à
prouver c'est comme un bon beh contre
lyon des lignes les plus hauts principal
de griffures bouaffou de y'en a répondu
avec les lignes qu'il a joué depuis
l'enfance donc oui si ces propos sept
dessins que le sacrifice de pyong c'est
très très très principale il ya votre
point de vue et le parti jouer dans
cette souriante leur est donc fausse e34
ok je sais que c'est là que là ça
commence avec scène depuis je suis pas
au courant dit elle je sais juste que ok
lebron beaucoup de deux avantages au
niveau de l'espace des plantes très
clair pour mater les noirs mais le reste
est flou killing est ce que c'est
possible que dans cette position serait
pas juste ça c'est pas possible
j'aurais joué cinq thèmes poupe oui je
pense pas que térez tu sais ce que ready
mort tu as n'ont pas souri t'aurais pas
réfléchi une longue temps ok 5 et ce qui
est aussi un jeu 5 maintenant il veut
jouer tour de huit mois c'est trop
dangereux de autour du don ces drivers
b5 avec les détours bo5
les bois 600 photos de cette fois-ci
roubles 5 quelque chose comme publicis
autour de 8 non mais j'aurais quand même
fait 5 même maintenant en fait semblant
d'hésitation l'homme qui sont aidées si
tu veux maintenant il est clair ceux qui
les ont aidés
il veut maintenir son col roulé sur une
piécette dans le surjeu 4 comme par
exemple au large sans keolis si ça j'ai
quelque chose qu'on sent que relève 5-fu
bouche d'un jeu qatari qui attaque et
moi je pensais que plutôt fois ci seront
aussi très loin des spécialistes puisque
fois ci c'est si bien puisqu'un était
blanc tu varane états d'âme en c4 était
plutôt content c'est pour ça juste moi
qui auger
jouer les green fields avec les noirs
qui ont pendant un an
je ne sais pas mal des pertes de
défaites en jouant ça à chaque fois le
club de sedan mots justes je comprends
pas ces positions de tout noir je
préfère presque toujours le noir elle
est bon et je dois dire qu'il faut être
un sacré calcul heures pour pouvoir
tenir tout ça juste moi comme envoyer le
ghana ils sont impressionnants mv les
gars n'ont aucune finale depuis six mois
sans crainte avec le noir jouent en
comment dire un mec qui fait du jogging
saoul et avec les brasseries qui fait du
karaté oui et donc le terril et déjà par
terre ils essaient de faire le contre
coup avec ses pieds mais sinon dans les
parterres
il a même pas de troisième sur qui bouge
ses pièces et le boucher doit bouger ses
pièces que sur la huitième et là c'était
vrai pour qui tu sais c'est pas très
bien de faire du ju jitsu contre kpatcha
mon avis pouvoir faire je pense qu'il
faut être blindé pour pouvoir tenir tout
le coup que tu vois que tu vas recevoir
en attendant le beau fuir le beau futur
e non mais contre le karaté tu as
peut-être une chance contre carpates ch
c'est déjà fini
[Musique]
dis moi très forte hausse de 5,4 tous
rêvent d un nom mais j'aurai fait tout
rêve d injuste parce que j'aurais eu
peur j'aurais voulu blanc démons pions
des 5
oui je pense que tu rêves des incas même
cessé il n'a pas peur d'eux cinq
peut-être je pense que j'ai vu ça
quelque part
si c'était une partie si c'est pas une
partie de jan peter et quand d'autres de
bon niveau mais j'ai vu le concept mais
je pense je suis pas sûr que ça va mal
c'est quoi c'est quoi l'idée en fait pas
se regrouper et coire enfin bouger les
pièces bouger les pieds s'est appuyé sur
les appuyer sur le bouton surtout pour
appuyer sur le bouton visage parce qu'au
fond je crois c'est le coup mais
peut-être penser tour b 3 wii et voyais
tout le monde espère que c'est bien le
détour
hewitt qui va bloquer le sertit du roi
et une fois là dedans voix se retrouver
sur un site web non mais fou j'ai 3 au
tour b mais fuji troisième bien et pour
cavaler g5 d'un match 4 ça c'est mes
plans mal mais surtout parce que ça fait
peur c'est surtout parce que ça fait
l'erreur
fou de 3 à vrai dire moi et vu que le
noir je leur dis de vérité les points de
vue
à l'instar de saulx qui a fait cinq
mille fois dans son match contre 15 là
il a abandonné plusieurs fois lorsque
c'était new le c'était juste un peu
moins bien il n'en pouvait plus mais les
cinq skippers maximalise comme l'
approche en tant que ces comptages
critique cette approche là parce que
aussi t'es pas au taupe en cours vont
mieux jouer pratique qui aux maximois
liste
donc vive au refuge et trois et que vos
livres 5 points d'interrogation je pense
pas qu'il est capable de calculer ce
qu'il faut calculer c'est trop difficile
à calculer un trait maximaliste en tant
que mais il est vrai qu'ils ont
maintenant à part de saddam sur h3oz car
il est vrai que l'état des menaces comme
je pense
justice tu es tu fais quoi là non je
comprends ces raisons mais m ces yankees
en phase donc ou mais pas si facile que
tout ne tient qu'à notre style nom kevin
associe dame b3 d'un match 3 d'ailleurs
dans les autres trucs qui peut vouloir
faire comme moi je crois au moins mais
si tu veux ou même dans ces trois dames
aux trois cinquièmes et y en a plus que
deux minutes là pour retrouver comment
s'en sortir il n'a pas un must il n'a
pas gardé les possibilités de mettre son
cavalier sur flippant là il peut pas
faire toi 8e et des fistules appelé
comment déjà ce cavalier fuite
le cavalier de dragon maritz qui c'est
un blitz blender légendaire à moscou ah
tiens très bien je pense que dans deux
cinq tours brice et si dame des quatre
bons fous 3 g attend vlad sur d'un des
cinq d'un match on a juste un match
aller au bout et non mais j'ai pas
compris b5 parce que de toute façon dame
b 3 tu as
ok pour l'instant mme sheeran ici à
noter si ce maïs est horrible mais ça
permet de continuer la partie mais qui
est cet effet si on peut faire moins des
six fg tour bossis avec les deux de ces
pasqua à 8,6 des 6 mg et 17 mai au caire
6 2 6 2 6 3 6 4 mais vlady la pète un
peu con grille de fer tour en dessins
qu'il aurait pu faire dame b3 direct et
y aurait pas eu l'idée d'am-dam s'est
vite parce que le calcul et nous avec
toi non oui oui donc je pense qu'il
devrait y avoir des raisons quoique ok
c'est pas un dieu non plus donc
maintenant de leur set peut-être moins
pas de prendre cette mode en justice oui
de recettes dargis six ans prend pas
tout doucement et torréfie de fois j
soit pas un frein à six des sept matches
ayant instauré de son répertoire bien
sûr s'essayant typique tout ça une fois
ce foutu le relais recommence d'être
créatif en couleurs à gauche un coup à
droite est assez horrible
sauf que rome
ça fait marrer après la partie mais ça
fait leurs preuves dans la partie voyait
lui complètement foutue bien sûr un
point n'importe quel coût on mangeait
pas des six par exemple vous puissiez sa
boîte robotisée à mado décide ce doit
être complètement gagnant en tout ce
qu'ils voulaient la mâchoire justesse 4
france f4
je sais pas du tout convaincu parce que
cette fois construite c'est justement
pour border ces trois hommes même si
rien d'horrible hockey des six il suit
il suit les instants que le clou les
plus ou moins ok une fois le co va
laisser le cera sur f5 bien sûr c'est
complètement un joueur boloss sauf pour
rien lorsqu'il est en train de se jouer
une auteure grunsfeld horrible d'alema
scan cavaliers f5 tour à tour besset
temple où est donc tour ce sens qu alors
autour de 55 enfants donc je peux pas
regarder si on veut rester en bon santé
vaut mieux donner pas regarder ça
passivement dure sept cavaliers bouge
cette ode à mousse 3 avec les deux dames
de 5 ou qui quoique quoi que vous voulez
et le tarn est arrivé peut-être pour
abandonner au cavalière sans que je
pense tempo seins nus à verdun massad
j'imagine mon tour 7h08 dames 2 6% à mu
peut-être peut-être tout un tour b 7
tours point f5 et dames c'est celle ci
avait dame problème de l'échec
ok damage trois fois je sais ce que
valait 5 très convaincant je sais il
faut pas réfléchir damas trois fois 6
turbo se pose après tobo s'est élevé à
abandonner mais j'ai remarqué parfois il
fallait mieux pas trop réfléchir dans
ses positions
à chaque photo dans le dos donc turbo 16
dames sérieux ça des fois encore tu
penses et tourbe fait tomber c'est dès
maintenant
wac le typique typique typique type
itunes mais change pas avec des années
dans vingt huit cavaliers de 5 3e partis
ou d'hommes jeu si ce qui est oui
pour l'instant la domination est quasi
totale dans les ouvertures - sinon brook
est le jouet un brin série ainsi que les
communes ready hockey comme je connais
[Musique]
ya en elle va répéter ce qui allait
ramener les victoires avant qu ils
voient comment ces d'un terreau but et
après il va changer oui pas tandis que
ça donne des résultats elle va toujours
continuer même si l'avantagé noir oui
mais ce sont les plus horribles il faut
d'ailleurs la france est son plus gros
défaut ce soir son plus grand défaut
d'ailleurs assez typique pour toi de
joueurs ils répètent les bons de
variantes
même si ce n'était pas bien pendant les
beaux pendant l'épreuve
d'ailleurs lors attendre la 12e être un
lien sur le chat je mets un lien vers
facebook sur le chat les mecs pour que
vous puissiez partager si vous kiffez le
match et que pas le match a bien démarré
ça semble être un match intéressant long
et serré donc j'ai mis un petit lien
dans le chat de tweets vous pouvez faire
un petit partage sur le sur le facebook
ça permettra à plus de gens d'être au
courant que le match est en cours et de
et de ramener plus de public là tu te
laisse te laisse reprendre quelqu'un
écrit qu'un regret chez hogan the grass
le relate le cas mais le pire c'est de
sa propre faute
c'est tout à fait ça merci infiniment
et c est ce que tu vas le fouetter pour
chaque défaite
oui mais pour cela il faut que je passe
à côté d'un magasin pour les adultes
mais je n'ai pas dans mon quartier de la
gare où ça mais tu te rappelles j'avais
un fou et chez moi je suis je viens très
proche de la garde meurt brusquement à
huy à cannes tivipro
de la gare souvent et maintenant vous
connaissez les raisons pourquoi c'est
vrai que la garde de cannes c'est plutôt
pas mal pour trouver ce genre d'objet
oui il est possible d'ailleurs qu'il se
trompait ici parce que à 6 après fou de
trois cavaliers ses 6 2 7 5
que voulez-vous huit mois après au fouet
forme peut-être pas si bien que ça parce
que parce que l'eau comme nous faut sur
détroit aurait boîtier la dame de
contrôler la quasi 3 wii et sinon ayant
fait il ya tant de définir ceci même de
toute manière je ne m'aime je sais pas
quelle est l'évolution correct mais
j'aime bien les noirs de toute manière
parce que oui kim wan si tu bouffes dans
beauséjour qu elle est boudée scène je
pense qu'il est très facile je bois
comme ben moi j'aurai tout le temps pris
les noirs enfin tu sais que je prends
toujours le jeu actif
quoi qu'il se passe je prends deux
joueurs actifs ok dans ce cas là
effectivement explique mois ci des oeufs
il veut faire quoi dans possible dans le
cinq donc 2e quart les 16 5 et 6 dans 2
5 pouces et 460 tient au quidam de 5 à
yushu finale n'ont de sens que les 2,5
comme allié n'importe quel 5 et le
cavalier bourhis surpoids non ou oui
peut prendre de la tour aussi peut-être
ça c'est justement à cause de les lignes
que je viens de dire que valve est bcp
plus principal peut-être sauf que comme
les cinq de saint cloud et 4 grand chose
mais qui connaissait son coin pour aller
vers le 4eme demande d'emprunt ou
peut-être le matin il dépend en train de
faire de la merde la grille ou pense qu
il est de nouveau moins bien un matin il
va voir des trucs et quand que tour
demain c'est pas possible via le fou qui
contrôle mais c'est juste pas du tout
l'impression ses positions la queue dès
que tu vas te prendre un cheapos une
tactique quelque part quoi bah ça dépend
qui maintenant par exemple le chipeau
c'est que nous
mais dans ce cas le suppose ce que le
menace les noirs et menace de gagner la
paix de la partie dans un coup et 6 à 3
tours 8
non mais 55 ans menace tbk trop rigoler
parce que c'est une menace surtout et
c'est ok premièrement sur la dame au
estienne quelque sorte ben brik atteint
7,2 et les fourchettes et a3 très vite
et fait beaucoup quoi est-ce que je peux
jouer g4 ici avec les blancs mais que
les deux accords à l'époque adamov 3 que
vous les cédez autour d un verre je vois
d'ailleurs je suis pas trop sûr que
c'est aussi bien que ça pour les bornes
de toute manière mère moi ou mois mais
les banquiers rois quoi enfin il a il a
une plage il avait un coup de retard
pour juger 4 c'est une loi qui voit
réputé jusque la fin de toujours me bats
toujours rien
chi chi chi le bonheur qui était connu à
l'époque à moscou qui n'a pas encore
joué ta fameuse par steve mason partie
de la fameuse ok moi et si c'est
intéressant quand vas tu va me prendre
pour un fou vlad mais tu sais à quoi je
pensais mais je pense pas que ça mais
moi je pense à dammaj 4 et 6 jaj que
vous allez le quintal bas salaires
intéressants je dois dire je vois pas de
réfutation direct madame h4 est accordé
3 1 ou 2 reprend des cinq hôtels ok donc
revenons à ton cou f6 non-jeu hockey et
si je mets marsoui 8 tu prouves et si
j'achète ce jour les commandes mais bon
mais bon
une position c'est toujours impossible
de évolué stratégiquement parce que les
blancs et les noirs on leurs points
forts et leurs points faibles et où
c'est hyper concret quoique j'ai
l'impression maintenant après le dernier
coup de doigt je pense que les boissons
de trois murs parce que lecavalier cinq
bourses ont trop fou sur à quatre il ya
plus de fourchette les bois on va
bouffer le fou sur le site d'un coup à
l'autre qui les besoins vont toujours
terrorisé les noirs de avec les charges
de dames avec les les meilleures finales
ce qui est en train d'arriver derrière
ah oui plutôt versé pas la pointe de
mentionner qu'il ya nettement améliorée
donc ok et les pronostics ne sont pas
bien de nouveau pour allart vlad si les
blancs sont mieux c'est parce que les
pions ses 7es à six sont faibles on est
d'accord notamment et c'est parce que ok
le solde sera noir c'est quoi c'est
l'activité de leur pièce mais le
problème c'est que les noirs jouent 502
x 7 c'est ça le problème et le problème
ce qui est aussi là aussi c'est que une
fois l'eau il faut aller aux cowboys
lecavalier brad voit arriver sur six est
fixé au collier sur ses six va juste
dominés tout sur l'échiquier comme les
autres rois était très bizarre comme
déjà voyait donc que voilées s'étaient
quoi fou de trop faut des trois tours
2-3 a créé le 5
food show complètement foutu et
tourcoing fc tours des huit matt aut et
moi pourquoi est-ce qu'il a pris sur un
dossier vide pour l'instant c'est que
c'est pour l'instant son état de forme
même impression pois du tour donc il est
bien préparée mef mer c'est sa seule
gloire mais l'auteur se débrouille
nettement mieux dans les positions
résultats tout simplement parce que
l'évolution n'est pas claire mais
l'odeur est plus rapide et hyper
pratique hippie reprise pratique dans
tous ses choix
elle réfléchit pas fidèle à ses
habitudes parce que c'est mon avis tu
dois jouer - camaïeu 4 le pion f2 un peu
faible je n'ai pas dit qu'il faut
bouffer le plus haut tout de suite après
ouais ok peut-être 5 il doit avoir une
victoire immédiate mais là où ils le
voient toujours pas moi non plus
d'heures il a fait ça quand même
quelqu'un ça il a view donc qu'elle va
jouer le reste de légionelles avec eux
une pièce de plus donc avec le roi de
plus beaucoup mais il n'a pas beaucoup
de moi tous donc plutôt direct quelques
chances
ok normand ce foutu bien sûr - et ce qui
veut faire flouer il voulait peut-être
tout est changé
will gagnante impôts importants avec sa
matraque de trois morceaux mélancoliques
quatre parcours mais les cavaliers les
cavaliers à lambesc plus peut-être
permettre au noir devoir de chance de la
sauver de sauvetage andes qu au oui
parce que les séquelles les cavaliers en
un desk dont cramique moi m'a parlé
pendant très très longtemps dans
l'interview que je ferai les couilles
pourquoi il tient à l'époque il m'a
parlé qu' il n'y avait jamais un tel
joueur qui a maîtrisé au tam
aussi bien des cavaliers que la
maintenant je sens que possible
d'ailleurs parce que pas de fous qu'eux
mêmes ne t'aime pas ce coup bas je
préfère je sens qu'avec les décors
quatre buts je crois pas quelque chose
c'est normal si je vous prends quelques
choses aillent efforts sans que ce
qu'elle est si je sens que x 5 avec les
des fours 4 c'est le cas des bougies ou
et donc aux acquis il ya un vieux
absolument simplifier la pose de dieu
sait si les réseaux parce que il ya plus
de perdre des fous et des télés est le
roi arrive maintenant ou plus facile de
jouer avec le noir qui avant manquait
mais le roi arrive quand même en premier
pour les blancs peut-être roi f3 ici à
beaucoup de il n'y a pas beaucoup du
matos c'est ça ce que est par contre un
problème c'est qu'il ya qu une seconde
de rajouts cette année et avant les
gardois combien deux avancées c'est ok à
chaque fois ils changent la cadence je
crois je suis pas sûr mais de mémoire
ces cinq + 2 avant de confirmer un super
mois mais plutôt terrain 5e buzzer comme
le technico il devrait préparer mais qui
qu'est-ce qu'il veut pas il a raté
quelque chose non il est devenu ou
fleurs là bien sûr il ya aucun problème
pour le noir mardi
d'ailleurs ce sont comme les n'est pas
mieux que le covan et de noir il a tout
raté donne de quoi je pense qu'il faut
cinq également possible mais c'est
incroyable non roy ou 90 cents croît de
4 collez vous trouve coudre il est un
titre incroyable il est utile réussir au
sein de la manière qu'on manie cahiers
et caro période parfois compte comme
caruana perd contre hikaru
normalement ce fouthiaux pour les boîtes
sauf acquis que les pions doublé dont de
l'espoir bien sûr à qatar marche si on
voit ça marche je pense pas qu'ils
tombent marché justement oui oui c'est
mc c'est nenê qui se comptent donc il ce
spi de lettres pur deux fois guéri en
mai il a raison oui dans ce cas là le
plus comblé mois elle va il va pas
gagner et il va falloir faire j 5 quand
même regarder récupère un peu de temps
il a sept secondes de nouveau à tiens
pour une fois il était précieux aux yeux
qui piquent collège six cavaliers
cynisme pourquoi korolev 6 collet
ok peut-être c'est pareil aux questions
et décès de rené lecavalier en tant que
ceo purgé 4 mois notre colère que
roberge s'est tenue ok ça va mieux et
peut-être qui joue un coup de cavaliers
et qu'ils aillent prendre le pion que là
il en train de répéter les coups juste
ah ok pas ton parfois justifiées comme
un résultat moins bon mais sur la partie
on va dire que c'est justifié non non
j'irai pas 10 parce que ce n'était qu'un
coup de folie de la part d'audience est
mon mail a très bien joué pendant toute
la partie
ok très intéressante parce qu'en fait
j'ai regardé les parties de mes premiers
chiffres sur cette ligne là et tout ça
lisse et pâques mais qu'est ce qu'il
veut au contraire ça toute sa vie c'est
pourquoi le ballet plupart des cas
précis il faut beaucoup dam de sa mère
c'est pas les pointes de tournon strada
dieuze nostradamus de mentir pour dire
que sacha doit être préparé et toi tu le
sais je sais je fais mais je sais pas
quand je sais pourquoi exactement je
veux même pas mentir je sais pas
great user qui est filmé de manière
assez marrante glycémie de profil par
rapport à sa caméra à il n'est pas comme
les gens normaux en face quoi les
profils au revoir mais les milieux c'est
quelqu'un ou un murmure de les aurais je
sais pas lien nuit qui efface cas mais
il a un il a un siège de gamer on voit
qu'ils jouent à dota 2 c'est sa voix
il est d'ailleurs si vous tapez ayant ni
premiers chiffres en russe sur google
c'est la première chose que vous allez
voir palais un joueur de chèques
légendaire mais un joueur très connu
d'autres bota bota beaucoup plus
intéressant que les échecs
oui oui pour moi je sais même pas de
quoi ça parle
c'est un truc qui ce quelle surprise sur
dame de set elle n'a pas eu de déplaire
peut-être qu'il a fait le prix m'ouvre
des 5
en attendant sa tendance de football cet
été le foot
oui c'est pas le moment de réfléchir tu
te fallait réfléchir plutôt que c'est
parce que ok je pense que normalement il
doit penser de quoi qu'il en soit pour
préparer des six après quoi il ya pas
mal de coups comme fou le qatar surtout
je pense fouet ce sens que si tu être
très sanglant des trois pères m'a fauché
quatre est aussi très intéressant bon ok
faut 5 août atteint le taux plus tôt ce
mois-ci soucier possible il me faut 5
ok alors dont le deuxième à leurs joutes
de tours 2-3
j'aime pas ça pour moi aujourd'hui je
pars sa forme du tout quoi ouah
d'impôts
ok tourbe quoi
le guen idée c'est que si tu prends un
f3 tu reprendre la dame il reprend il
prend 1,5 et tu feras fou 4 à la fin et
ça fera moins m'ont aidé dont je sais
pas trop fier parce que c'est les délais
plus primitif que tu peux voir au quai
de prendre à nous dire que ce soit
maintenant parce que je vais pas jouer
d'épicier ou en tant qu'île hyper dur
pour moi de te taire alors quelque chose
qu'on fout eu deux parce que ça stoppe
de recettes stuff trois oui mais dans ce
cas là il faut 5 oui recueille le séisme
non mais juste mal là non je pense qu il
peut être allez pas trop bien mais
peut-être sonné des squares ou kiko et
les 6,6 au four 5
je pense ce qu'il a fait j'aime pas du
tout la trêve qui peut faire dan 17 la
touques un carrier g5 1
madame 17h07 merde y'a plus dans
l'hémicycle quoi dire je parie déjà pour
commencer à tianli des dames h4
d'embouts trois ans ni après quoi que
valider quatre pierres davos et 3 8
d'avancé sur ogier d'infos ce cap est
donc dans deux trois ans attend attend
un petit peu aussi en attente en juillet
qu'est ce que c'est intéressant
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs les parties comme
gars jouent avec les bornes sont très
intéressants mais je trouve que c'est
encore plus intéressant qu'un meilleur
joue avec une oie parce qu'ils paient un
mois le courage du style l'arn
opportuniste l'autre un lot vrai comme à
dire le voyais resortissants de l'école
bobigny que très intéressant tout ça
vient il a l'air en pls il a l'air en
sueur devant son écran là ils ne
regardent même pas les grands les curés
quoi mais il perd comment un profond
sens que damas et trois suisses et trois
à damas six dames 8 oui qui viennent
peut-être tu peux expliquer ça qui est
bien méchante reine est en train de
montrer viable à moi je peux pas les
voir eux tu peux pas le voir mais
n'oublie pas que même pour moi tu vas
vite mais pas pour eux
oui il a complètement vous plaît comme
moi d'ailleurs comme toi aussi l'aider
dock valley de 5 et d'un bo3 non mais ça
c'était un sujet critique et sasha est
donc je dois dire que je vous parle
est ce qu'on peut dire qui tu as fait
fermer ta gueule quelque part ouais
ouais
elle m'a bien faire mais moi je l'admets
dame aux cèpes 3 je suis je crois que
vous les d4 c'est plutôt tersana de
mater sur 2 1 au québec et chef du
stream est malin je connais très bien ce
mec mais qu'est ce que ça donne je vois
pas fous rires et fous de 3 mg page dans
ma chambre et je m'attends à voir ya
découvert ça aide toujours pas de sauver
la partie juste je résiste toujours
qu'après je trouve les noirs doivent
abandonner parce que comme les des katas
fou des années le sur le ku'damm
archives dames 8 et va recevoir dans une
autre les cavaliers des 400 coups de
fouet une vague quand même un ok mais
c'est typique jan - si c'est pas beau il
doit le faire de toute manière juste
pour comme quoi se frotter tiens t'as
pas tout ça
moi je vais audience si brillant ne
pourra pas vraiment pourquoi est ce que
c'est que ça c'est quoi ça ok au lieu de
gagner la torre préfère de gagner le fou
ou bien la toux et lofo marocaine et son
idée s'échauffent
ok mais il marque un relief trois échecs
ok tout ce que tu veux retrouver cette
force est un signe avec la manière 3
chaque grade mais qu'est-ce qui le
formulaire à la fin du compte il va
gagner que la qualité
après des mots 6 il faut encore gagner
la partie est trop de boue mais au lieu
de cela elle aurait pu gagner la tournée
qu'est-ce que c'était ce qu'on a pas vu
quelque chose hein pas non je pense qu
il ya dedans je m'en fous je sens un
cafouillage faut à six russie s'est tu
gagnes avec eux et tu gagnes avec eux la
dame le pion sur cet auteur de pièces
mais olalalala bizarre bizarre bizarre
là par contre l hyper dur de gagner
parce que y'a même pas de tournant pour
cause de corée 3 voilà donc ça marche tu
es les les conneries d' allah allah
l'ayant non mais là il faut quand même
rythme en sont gagnants normal moi
mouais c'est du secret boulot au tour de
trois absolument quoique roi est fort
n'est pas ciblé siffle là il faut il
faut il faut quand même souligner quand
même là la puissance de yann là je crois
que c'est quand même important de la
touriste
là c'est quand même important de dire
que iana c'est oui oui qui me qu'ils
puissent un set qui sans cela auraient
jamais marcher contre moi c'est le plus
à ce que j'aurai un peu j'aurais tourné
en puissance mais bon il joue contre un
joueur plus faible que je n'ai pas dit
ok les boissons gagnant à 5 e oui c'est
compréhensible ne doit pas aider de
sauver le parti tient cette firme est
chez moi là mais il faut que tu
actualise parce que t'as pas toucher à
un échiquier pendant une heure c'est
fermer quoi mais bon du coup ils
entendent tout ça les droits il ya un
bête
ma chère amie
ça ressemble énormément à l'une des
parties de dieu manchot fischer spassky
à reykjavik
celles qui fischer a gagné dans le
système brière avec les banques ces
récents boîte beaucoup leur sort ce que
je pense que la tâche de soutenir a été
plus dur dans cette partie que celle de
griche oublie ici parce que ça se voit
que c'est gagnant juste il faut être
pratique rapide et est ce que tu échange
d'une paire de tour ou pas ça dépend
parce qu'il peut y avoir des situations
quand la marche 3 6 3 de 5
très friand
la mahatma il faut qu'il faut comprendre
qu est-ce qui lui offert contre tours
échangent sur matoub 5 donc tous et si
ce qui est très très très typiques ont
bien à tour 6-4 par hé oui le doigt de
télé comment dire à tes les mouvements
des pièces allaient vitesse cosmique et
peut pas faire tout rend malade pour
éviter cinq tours un tour vient
maintenant l'idée principale c'est que
les besoins voudront donc transporter la
tour sur le site hymne et organiser des
dommages
oui donc je pense pas que c'est possible
d'éviter de d'éviter ça donc ce n'est
que les questions du temps à ok tout
raciste ou sud
après quoi oui tout arraché ce pardon de
3-6 7-6 rhodia fait entourage ses torts
à des prix records h3g six tours de 7
200 f 5 matin je lis un mois après rien
fait
elle discutera ensuite marche pas donc
tour de suspicion autour des 6 tours de
6 des deux roues f3 à 4 2 à 3 tours à 6
jason kidd dakota emprunt autant prêt
oui mais je suis pas sûr que c'est le
seul moyen de 5 à 3 et 6 à 12 900
qu'avec les dea en tour du web the six
mois j'ai pas le temps demain de montrer
j'ai compris vrai mais ok il fait ce
truc là à trois tours à six robots
quatre tours à 4 et 6 fautes de 6-3 2-2
à 2.306 gritche reprend le dessus vlad
qui explosent en caisse la première fois
grille tout mène dans le match ok mais
peut-être le temps m'est arrivé de
gagner avec les noirs déjà acquis il est
pas content de la suite des événements
normal tiens ils jouent presque jamais
ça peut-être jamais d'ailleurs parce que
y'en ai connu pour été reçue et qui
avance et les modos h3 a prévu le coup
de fraîcheur dans la nage dorff howey et
fouché 5 6 des 9 3 ça existe bien sûr
depuis toujours mais c'est une ligne
considéré très très très moyen pour les
baux elle n'est pas jouée par des forces
dur de tout d'ailleurs foule après fou
je sens que si je trouve ce que plus
intéressant c'est les lignes kazakh dame
de 3 m ok je le frapperai là on n'a pas
le temps là de montrer ce qu il veut
donc qu'est ce que veut y a il veut
comme il a provoqué le courage s'il veut
mettre sa dame sûr je crois pour
justement provoquer les noirs de jouer
soit 5 soit je suis donc publié le roi
et donc pour avoir des idées tactiques
et donc mais du coup quand tu fais g5 tu
gagnes la case de 5 quand même pour ton
caries ça peut être intéressant chaque
fois élevé offert sa tante que la dame
au cirage trois peut-être élevé aussi tu
veux faire ça at il dit il il est
peut-être il voulait faire ça une fois
les boissons de requérir d'accord de
toute manière les dés de noix déboires
après une fois là dans mon entourage toi
c'est que sur je sens que les bons fous
je sens
battant mais j'aime pas du tout les
noirs là moi non plus je pense que comme
alliage 5 maintenant c'est clair que ça
a été moins joué il a juste perdu du
temps peut-être il faut le jouer je sens
que je peux toujours je sens que nous
pas enfin je sens tout de suite mais là
elle se retrouverait dans une situation
pas agréable typique pour les siciliens
quand je sais pas vraiment où est ce que
tu vois des rats qui ne pensent qu'au
plus tôt auquel on a là non ferreux 5 ha
non non non ce rythme là les lots
pouvoir y jouer sur trois avec des idées
comme à saintes publicis ma chance est
très dangereuse américain et du coup tu
vas ou puisque petit rock d'angers 3 au
caire où elle fit heures
jamais c'est horrible parce que tu
pourras pas jouer des 5
c'est très désagréable mais souvent les
bois mire de toutes les situations tout
simplement parce que trop content de
l'issue de l'ouverture trop content de
comment ça s'est passé
donc parce que en gros tout tout est bon
ici pour les bourgs jeu paroisse champ
des bombes damage trouver un bon maire
normal et blanc veut tout et tout de
suite ça des cats a pas réussi très
logique
je pense qu'ils menacent des cinq
d'ailleurs la non stratégique man who
was louisiane sud s'était il veut faire
il veut se retire qui s'était il faut
conquérir ce marché attend est ce qui
peut faire cavalier prend et fouet f6 et
essayer de vie c'est l'iphone tenir la
case f6 tombe bien je mal parce que
l'auteur veut faire quelque chose qu'on
valait aussi ses feux d'un no 7 et
france 3 est rentrée sur recettes avec
la tour à la porte restée ouverte c'est
à fos travaux de 5 comme les u6
tiens qu'est-ce qu'il veut la foudre des
et qu'est-ce qui les préparent et
cavaliers sicoval et ses 6 pouces 3 que
valeo 6 3 bouche toujours pas de
catastrophe
maintenant on va voir ça râle rouages
c'est très dangereux de foot de 5 a été
beaucoup plus principal est beaucoup
plus fort alors parce que justement il
n'a pas compris l'idée du mec
son idée a été de sacrifier les locaux
voyaient ce que j'ai dit ouais mais
peut-être qu'il a vu un truc un sursis
mais c est qu est ce que les élèves
aient eu à propos de sa carrière de voir
mouchoirs fou peut-être pour toi quoi et
a été peut-être que valeo 6 faut se
croire que vous allez je sais tu qui vit
fougeux 7 et 6 enfants dont 40 unis sur
food et 5 qui avait lui aussi eu ce
qu'ils savaient que les deux roues ces
trois grands voyagistes le set où la 1è
sur oise il surfe ou g7 f6 croit guère
il n'a pas le thorax est là d'ailleurs
c'est possible d'oublier tout ça et là
elle réfléchit mais il est trop tard de
réfléchir inquiète elle me prend des
jouets avec afi 6 et mais bon ça pue
quoi le cavalier super fort basse juste
c'est la france tu fais quoi que ce soit
quoique tu veux moi je pense qu'il veut
faire tourner the wit moquer mais c'est
incroyable loupé une fois tu vois
comment les u 6 et u bouffe ou tu fais
tes yeux tu bouffes sur cinq rencontres
sur quoi tu permets pas ça non mais tu
es obligé de faire tourner vite puisque
six f 16 e f e dame ce huit dames de
trois rouages de 8 avec les dettes de
recettes dans ce sens croissante dans
des sacs d'os d'hommes jeu 6 doubles
jeux de wii voici bouffe abandon et feu
qui est en train de montrer la ligne ok
mais là ça la finale elles pullulent à
de stressant non non non rires % je veux
pas raison et moi pas si j'ai six
termine que voyage sans gagner je te
refais bon bon bon ok ça va pas durer
longtemps ça n'arrive à faire buter là
non c'est incroyable mais les besoins
gagne presque toutes les parties si les
boues un gameplay les banques devaient
gagner nous terrible a plus rien comme
peut-être qui tombe fou prend des saints
qui a abandonné après quoi fou de saddam
de trois droites 8 et agir et
abandonnent et turbans des caméras
mais après à feu
comment exactement les banques d'août
sont en fait je veux pas dans ceux ci
pour avoir les idées de
ce cri fils adam sur le dossier jamais
jaillir connais deux pions hockey comme
le fou ok de bas je pensais dame ces six
prises prise à vii et e7 mais ça n'a pas
marché parce que le fou contrôle oui oui
il va faire f77 et et va gagner oui il
va gagner les qualités un joueur de foot
ouais ouais ok la finale moi je
comprends ok je dois dire est
impressionnant quoi impressionner
impressionnant de la part de yann et
pour l'instant ça sharif pas du tout de
résoudre ses problèmes avec noir malgré
qu'ils obtiennent des poses de correct
mais c'est un beau matin c'est le plus
beau match de l'année je pense pour le
moment c'est serré ça joue bien des deux
côtés le match maxime était déjà bien
mais là ça joue encore mieux quoi je
passe levier mais j'aime bien ce match
mais il est vrai ok je suis contente de
le commenter
j'aurais pu être très contents tant que
spectateur très serré très intéressant
comparable au niveau audio au niveau du
comédien au niveau de la force de la
forme de joueurs les deux joues bien
mais c'est sympa quand c'est serré toute
façon ce n'est pas marrant ces séquences
aussi et est ce que y'a va reprendre son
greenfield parce que il n'a pas essayé
même trois fois il a lâché son arme
principale
après deux partis noirs de jais
quoiqu'on il aurait pas pu ou su
reprendre gris choc avec la green fields
presque leningrad ce qu'on appelle ne
reviendra pas ce qu'il a fait cinq mille
fois déjà avec moi dans ce set c'est pas
le cours à la mode je pense je pense que
damas 5 et plus à la mode
attendre la danse fait un petit tweet
ouais ok il est assez évident que les
banques doivent être mieux parce que je
n'aime pas c'est cet enchaînement de
coups tour 8 dans le site que vous les
deux sets pensent que nous les noirs
sont trop sont trop affaibli pour
pouvoir jouer si mélancoliquement par
contre skill principal et c est ce qu il
ya quelque chose de maintenant le mot
mélancolique tu le connais grâce à
verlaine depuis toujours parce que c'est
un mot très souvent utilisée par le tu
me connais très bien très souvent je
suis de l'esprit mélancolique tu es plus
mélancolique que nostalgique je pense
oui oui d'ailleurs je pense qu'il est
assez bizarre de ternes antalgiques pour
un joueur d'échecs parce que un joueur
de chez que c'est très bien en avance
que de quoi il s'agit d'être nostalgique
du passé s'il ya autant d échec encore
de l'écriture des échecs dans tous les
sens surtout des échecs avec un s à la
fin et que oui
je suis en train de finir le les tweets
en fait à vous servir
ce qui est important pour ce type de
position autre que très souvent les
brandons en bout on inventa les
l'ordinateur donne un bon avantage aux
blancs dans les différentes mais ils
forment c'est pas si facile de co2 de
jouer sur l'échiquier en ferait donc
celui qui a plus d'expérience il est un
grand avantage sur ce week qui n'allait
pas est ce que tu veux dire qu'une
nouvelle fois la phrase du soir tout
n'est pas si facile tout ne tient qu'un
autre style s'emploie pour cette
position bah je pense que c'est bien le
cas je n'ai pas du tout aimé que valide
de cette tour vite tout le concept de la
mep là le plus je regarde les positions
de noir le plus je me demande qu'est ce
que les bonnes nouvelles à attendre la
très pompeux tripiers il veut mettre sa
dame sur trois maintenant
ouais après damas trois damas ans qui
était possible donc dans deux gros lots
4 vous réputé du coup à l'europe mais
peut-être dame e3 après la turquie
leucate et à terme à saint avit les d4
foot cup attend on va être juste
répondre à une question dans le chat de
giulia lim qui demandent en fait quel
est le format du match en fait on joue
pendant trois heures c'est pas une
question point c'est une question de
temps à trois tiers-temps entre
guillemets un tiers-temps 5 + 1 sont en
train de regarder cette cadence après il
y aura un deuxième tiers-temps d'une
heure en 3 + 1 puis 1 donne un dernier
tiers temps 1 + 1 et donc le match va se
finir à 21h pile en fait pas un
peut-être 21h05 sur à des breaks mais en
gros cette fille aux alentours de 21h
et donc à 21h05 celui qui a le plus de
ports à gagner le match
black c'était pour expliquer un petit
peu à vos auditeurs qui arrive ceux à
qui connaissent pas parce qu'on dit dans
le chat on et 530 ce qui est vraiment
beaucoup pour un match sans joueur
français donc si elle revient dans la
position qui en a maintenant sur
l'échiquier je préfère les noix parce
que les hauts fonds et moi le placer sur
trois est le problème de telco contours
des séances est fou de 80 après quoi
malgré les avantages de fucile noires
qui doivent être préféré à cause du pion
sur 2,5
une fois ce les pions sont des sons
doublé oui en fait je vais choquer mais
je suis pas d'accord avec toi je pense
que tours d'essai 1
si tu bouffes bouffant des quatre jeux
même à tour ans et 7 et mes pions double
et empêche de bouger je veux faire le
plan com - f12 roi des trois oui mais
après tour de c1 je vais faire [ __ ] 4
des taux s'est doté d'autres suis tout
de suite et je veux dévissé d'un la
finale des fous du coup les reposer avec
un point de plus parce que je veux
gagner 2,5 n'était plus moi il est
possible que c'est nul
alors il est possible que c'est parce
que c'est ce qui va se produire des
émeutes à tous et d'autres sites dont
celui de fos et 8 puis riche qui va
trouver comment il va perdre le pion de
5 et comment elle va tenir la forteresse
où est donc une chance inouïe de la même
manière contre le mausolée avec deux
points en deux mois donc bien sûr je
pense que objectivement c'est nul alors
ok maintenant les boutiques nick
peut-être c'est fou c'est en fout brice
est quelque chose qu'on a cabo catoche
route 204 à saint caprais
maintenant je pense qu'il faut pas jouer
à trois voies sont plaints parce que
yukio sur a3 prime 2 5 a été décrit mais
je fais confiance à grid pour faire nul
là quand même non oui mais c'est comme
même désagréables tout à fait
intéressant je leur ai préféré faut
juste valeur parce que personne ne l'a
dépêché de jeux d'eau gros caissons
foule n'a manqué il peut faire un set up
avec le foin ont peut-être oui ok il
vire fou de deux fours ont ils vu la
femme c'est pas moi qui vois apprendre
richemont 2,2 g de telles rumeurs
non mais je pense que c'est bien joué ce
qu'il fait ce qu'ils ont ni leurs pieds
une seule fois de l'école de botanique
ils ont toujours mille fois d' avance
sur les autres qu'ils n'ont pas fait lui
il était un petit peu de lait coule
bucnik moi je me non mais je pense qu'il
avait l'idée il a fait froid parce qu'il
avait l'idée de faire roi ces quatre
dessins que 5 et des quatre échecs je
pense et c'est pour cela qu'il a fait
froid ah oui c'est vrai c'est vrai
mondiale et les banques doivent être
capables de pouvoir
je veux dire par là ça doit être nul
mais je veux dire que le froid c'était
important
non mais s'était froissé très bien joué
blague je te voir jouer deux sens
qu'après 5 2 des 4 mai non mais tu peux
même laissé peut-être tu peux laisser
faire peser et ramener son rang même
peut-être wiimote d'ailleurs tu peu de
ses points de choses en fait puisque les
pions doublé sera pas si grave mais
c'est la première partie que les noirs
dominent
oui sofiane comme palais fait mal de la
deuxième partie et de gris choc avec le
noir d'un game c'était un peu
rocambolesques ici c'est beaucoup plus
justifiée je j'avoue d'ailleurs après
des cats et un peu je mens droit de 2e
cat et moi ça me fout de 2,4 oui c'est
très facile vers c'est typique aussi
comme comme les techniques a prêté
quatre à peugeot moindre ou cadres alors
la dir est encore 30 minutes de 5 + 1
est ce que tu penses
est ce que tu penses que gris cube peut
être satisfait de ce segment pour le
moment parce que il ya un an bullet
c'est fort quand même
bon ben je pense pas qu'ils ont à
présent gré choc se considère comme un
témoin moin bien que google y en dans
les bullet jeux d'adressé cannes c'est
dire comment tu au moins bien mais pas
beaucoup de toute manière mais bien sûr
il veut quand même accumulé quelque
chose même en petit quelque chose avant
qu'il n'y arrive mais bien sûr bien sûr
parce que d'autres manières normalement
les moines du temple le plus c'est un
faveur de gains pour qu'il joue répit de
toute maniére normalement mais je suis
en train de fuir suffisait sans recevoir
et du cou ok ça veut dire que c'est pas
forcément un super début de match pour
great choc malgré tout on non sa voix
moi ici la lpr presse il faut nul il
retient toujours plus on n'ose pas ou
c'est non segal segal il allie la
période à une autre
si sega les six égal si c'est grave bien
sûr c'est pas c'est pas parfait
donc non non c est surtout de toute
manière ce que désagréable où il est
toujours très très loin d'être efficace
avec les doigts c 'est toujours horrible
lorsque tu fais un brouillon de match
d'oubli ce que tu souffres avec eux
l'une des couleurs parce que ça fait
comme à dire parce que ça te ferait ça
te force à faire les concessions - avec
les banques tu vois ce que je veux moi
je sais tu sais qu'il ya le même système
au tennis ils disent que quand tu dois
souffrir pour tenir ton service si ça
dure trop longtemps
c'est difficile de briques et parce que
tu tu vois tu dois souffrir à chaque
fois l étape plus d'énergie après pour
trop dur mentalement ok des fois c'est
l'inversé qui se passera pour quazar
joue pas je vais mettre un peu les
caméras des joueurs on va voir yann qui
est parti ah oui oui aux jeux vidéo et
il ya un an lorsque je reviens je pense
qu'il partait souvent de l'étoile et
d'air il ressemble à moi d'aller dans
les échecs of one n'a été ainsi tu
t'appelles en serial pisseurs non ouais
je le suis intégrer qt il se tient la
tête entre les mains
ça va être physique aussi comme match ça
peut se jouer au physique est ce que tu
penses que great ou qu'il est bien
physiquement il a bien dormi avant tu
lui a filé des amendes à manger il se
nourrit pas d'ailleurs faux longueuil
quoi qu' il ait pas et l'est pas car
c'est sans aucun doute
ouais je pense que si on reste objectif
et on regarde
la pnue physique de yann je pense que 1
sans doute que les mieux préparés
physiquement accueilli à sa charge oui
mais sacha ils bouffent pas géré
normalement il devrait être en train de
bouffer des noirs
pourquoi thibault jamais d'ailleurs moi
même avant la partie ils bouffent pas
que port oui mais c'est pas bien quoi
fin il doit bouffer mais chacun à sa
constitution du cours différentes
ok quand même quand même au troisième
ouverture
est-ce qu'il va jouer à youri j'espère y
fasse des 5 j'aime pas ça je pars ça
presque normalement county au frais le
le chevalier comme ça et tu changes de
ces vertueux ça donc pas des résultats
mais ça dépend si tu es un chevalier
templier quoi peut-être là ça marche
et bien sûr n'est pas content des
pitchouns
il répète ses propres parties le fait
toujours il vient de voir une partie
comme ça reste ma à dortmund avec alice
3 et l échange sur deux points
- l'auteur n'a pas joué que valait 2 est
donc là pour faire semblant que con quoi
elle est bien le préparer il joue à 85
très vite mais en fait ce n'est bien sûr
départ du tour à ça de la part de sacha
donc il joue juste parce qu il adore
bluffait n'y suis pas le comtat le
conseil de moore tassé joue vite et bien
ok la justification est par contre les
justifications positionner les lire
comme souvent dans cette partie il veut
dire que si les noirs présents sur ces 4
après dans ces quatre fous bouge les
bras tout de suite pour un couple terre
vont jouer à 6 c'est comment dire
affaiblir ses six justement frapper sur
les structures des pions donc se
justifier mais ok quelqu'un qui a
analysé petro comme moi est très
sceptique envers le lcd comme ça parce
que est ce que tu penses que tu es un
des joueurs qui a le plus analysé les
ouvertures en actif en ce moment
bon il est possible mais je l' ai
commencé il ya assez peu de temps donc
je peux pas me comparer en cours avec
quelqu'un comme il sait le casting quoi
cela quand tu devrais stakhanoviste
stakhanoviste oui moi j'ai commencé il
ya que deux ans donc gamin pas encore
peut-être savoir iv me point quoi mais
tu es quand même un excellent
spécialiste des ouvertures aujourd'hui
parce que je me débrouille plutôt coeur
mais genre était dans le top 10 mondial
n'ont donc de toute manière dans le top
10 mondial il faut compter que ceux qui
jouent on ne peut pas compter et les
alizés les annales éthiciens parce que
ok j'ai mes fichiers bourré d analyse
mais déjà ceux qui sont d'abord
qu'est-ce que je me souvienne et comment
je veux traiter ça écoutez j'aime pas du
nouveau gm pas comme un guichet où je
serai avec de nouveaux coups nouveau je
veux le critiquer parce que parce que je
pense pas que c'est pour ça c'est bien
traités là mais ça m'a l'air horrible il
a donné la colonne à la tour et rentrer
sur la 7e la dame ses quatre gardes
aussi le pion à vii le pion c6 faible
toutes les pièces blanches active les
pièces noires fin tu joues sur deux
rangées
non je suis pas sûr que c'est aussi
dramatique que ça mais c'est son nom a
déjà il devrait jouer à six parce qu'il
avait trop peur de jouer tour à 8 à
cause d'eux des causes de poids d'air
est ce que tu vois là
les réfutations des douanes n'ont pas dû
hésiter non mais ça marche pas quoi
exactement huit ans parce que tous ravis
de ces lecoutre tient à la fois 5
maintenant bien sûr il est oublié fois
sans qu'il ait très vite jouée boussens
qu'elle ait oublié attendu invite à tan
tan tan en ville explique nous tous
ravis deux fois 5 c'est quoi le problème
pour ce 7e tour 17
enfin il ya dame de 80 ans d'où l'idée
de h3c pour pas qu'ils aient de maths du
couloir à la fin quoique il n'y aurait
pas une manne du cou lorsqu'elle cavani
mais peut-être dans certaines variantes
qu'on voit pas qui est maintenant sans
aucun doute sans réfléchir manque de
recettes
parce que tous cette fois 5 donc mais
qu'est-ce qui lé triki quoi ce mec donc
tout recettes sans réfléchir 6 x 5 de
8,1 vieux jouets que vous lis ici c'est
mon souffle
la hausse est tout autre et à collège
cadres et de nouveau le cavagnan f5 qui
revient de nouveau ce fameux que voilier
qui fait l'horreur des landes commence
au point at-il à attila dans l'oubli de
soi alors à temps il se passe quoi en
surpoids cinq dames se sent très vite
amadeus et 7
oui parce qu'avant il est préparé il a
défendu le cas soc est donc jusque j'ai
pas vu avant et maintenant peut-être sur
site mais il ya des modes de recettes
dans la foulée vite c'est bien joué il a
très bien joué il veut peut-être
cavaliers baissé ce qui est des cinq a
pris aux cavaliers ces quatre mêmes et
ça va il va faire soit tout soit 3,8 ce
que tu as eu trop modeste et matt damon
le web n'est ce pas mais j'aime bien
quand c'est rien ça vlad genre cavani
hamsik cavani des cinq élèves il faut
parler perdu son avantage
même s'il était classé clairement à
millau d'ailleurs il faut faire gaffe
maintenant parce qu'avec le cavalier sur
2,5 à un moment donné les clés l'ailé
les pièces à tout raciste d'amado tout
d'un coup peuvent se retrouver malgré
soeur et blablabla n'oublie pas que la
case age ii est contrôlé par le fou si
jamais ok bien
je m'attendais à ça ok mais bouffé
cavaliers des cinq peut-être juste fou
5e volet de 5 celle plus en plus mais ça
m'étonnerait si les noirs ont des
problèmes avait parlé de cette hausse
hier après quand les 2 5 août de retour
à cet emploi - kim est ok je vois pas de
problème il peut pas y avoir de problème
c'étaient les façons de peut-être deux
d'où justement à de s'en sortir et faire
mieux parce que c'est dans ce cadre
tueur 5 course e 6 5 est ok tu sais
comment murtha s'appelle ce genre de
position quand égalise bon il dit et
c'est ça va une traduction très murtha
lesques de it's ok c'est sympa
s'amuse adore quand il dit ça ça m'a
toujours fait rire je l'ait jamais
corrigé exprès et 6e sa valeur après
terrain à thiers il veut peut-être dire
que peut-être f4 oui c'est ça qu'il veut
jouer les cases blanches
ouais je suis pas mais c'est dangereux
il va prendre g4 est très opportuniste
et déjà et y aurait juste aucune raison
mais j'ai pas vu au bout qu'est ce que
c'est parce que produire 5 mai à vous
donc en fait il est le candidat eelv est
compliqué non mais je comprends pas il
veut compliqué avec deux minutes deux
mois la pendule est contre eux yann en
plus est ce que ce serait pas un choix
soupçonnant vlad je pense que c'est très
simple sans cela je peux te terrible de
faire ça c'est quand il y en a peut-être
le fait rage non ok très soupçonnant
comme son choix très soupçonneux
ok maintenant bien sûr une pensée dans
bout d'eux mêmes
bouraoui 3,7 damas quatre jeux 6 1 5
enfant de telles conneries à quoi que il
ya des mots simples qui ne doit pas été
mauvais mais le poisson sur 24 je suis
sur sa cavale il sera en tout cas malien
26 points fou et 56 fg roi jeu set et
qu'est-ce que ça donc que le dieu que le
bon dieu sauve à khalis f1 que valeo 4 e
f g 5 roi ashton non ça doit pas marcher
comme ce sac
je sais pas vous l'âme on va regarder en
live et sirois jeu c'est dommage car
dame aux cinq caméras g7 et a pu en
prendre six échecs lol ok je sais que ça
va c'est ridicule je te faisais mon
langage mais c'est du suicide
je vous le souci de bien n'a pas du tout
mérité de gagner c'est horrible il n'y a
aucun échec qui marchent également
baissé le rideau
incroyable cet enchaînement de coups en
commençant lecture au sénat autorise
donc pour l'instant en prison - ou
peut-être faire une conclusion que sacha
gagne avec la classe donc avec les mains
et il perd parce qu il ait pas au taux
plein
honnêtement vlad ça sent le scénario où
il va finir par se faire buter située à
l'armement pas que scénario mais je
reste toujours optimiste respect
alarmant mais c'est très important
maintenant de poser des problèmes
belle ouverture maintenant pour qu une
gamme panique
pierrick mois par an parce que si
l'auteur voit toujours oui torturé avec
les bois doit regagner mains et n'avoir
pas de problème avec le noir ce tracé le
pire scénario cauchemar mais pour quoi
il retourne pas dans l'espagnol c'était
pas si mal
lebrun ce que je pense que il avait des
problèmes pour s'en souvenir puisque les
regarde et qui est peut-être qu'ils
aillent voir pendant la petite pause il
sait très bien l'évolution du truc mais
elle se souvient pas comment voilà c'est
ça le problème
moi je suis et je ferai très sage
maintenant comme quoi jo c'est
l'évolution de tout mais je ne suis pas
sur l'échiquier
donc je comprends ce problème est bien
ici et je peux faire ses singles annie
sié ce qu'il faudrait faire c'est 5
oui kim s'est toujours questionnant
brûle comme un et 2 5 passes que
d'oublier de pions comme ça c'est
dangereux si les appuyer le pionner sur
bordeaux à cause d'eux dans votre
éventuel mais le problème c'est que
depuis un an sur deux ou trois rues un
peu pas avoir tous même temps
le fou sur trois et le reste qui est de
toute manière je pense que c'est très
surprenant ce qu'il dément nous on ne
peut pas parce que s'il faut de 4,17 que
valait 4 200 qui arrive et si je sens
qu'il ya toujours quatre thématiques
thématiques tout autant même sans trop
réfléchir aux cathos poursuit france est
très important que great gig égalise la
vlad pour la dynamique du match à moi
qu'ils ont pas encore c'est ce serait
agréable bien sûr mais c'est pas en cour
d'appel
ma vie dans les mascareignes eu droit
aux quais peu importe
richaud que c'est un jeu maximaliste
donc il pose les questions directes
j'attaque jeu 5
qu'est ce que tu as c'est très hostile
dans le style de eti et de niveau de jeu
à cinq mais pas avec les b à 4 et les cg
cinq reprises oui oui c'est très très
très à l'aise pour à 100 kg à 14 h force
enfin pour des photos bordel de cette
manière là et bosser cavale et des sacs
mais je pense pas que ça donc quelque
chose de concret quoique ce possible je
veux prendre prendre et faire kébé 5e
commandes de ces poussées que vallée des
saints quelle idée c'est encore plus
fort parce que surprise vous prend et
fourchette
oui sinon peut-être les bleus quatre
mois je suis pas sûr roy charge je pense
ok maintenant peut-être le tamari oui
pour tous la même chose avec un temps de
plus d'une fois
provost oui mes chers amis il ya aussi
de tel truc conflit social pour juste
pour bloquer les diagonales et pour
bouffer sur 2,5 plus par eux c'est
intéressant aussi
il ya d'ailleurs des eaux et on attend
une chose est sûre cavaliers prend un
bruit comme en quarts ni des cinq du
goût je fais pas de sport cavaliers des
cinq ici n'est pas beau de se défouler
ministre pauvres donc il a brouillé les
diagonales et me tape le plus
probablement elle va jouer mais attends
là ça devient de plus en plus bizarre
mais il doit y avoir une idée très
concrète lablad et c'est dans ce sens
que voler de 5 dans besoin d'en avant et
tout ceci ce prix ah oui qui savent
allier ces sept aussi je crois qu est ce
que je vois oui oui le décès est bien
sûr de faire chuter les réussites de
broc et les diagana qu'il ya plus de
cavaliers ou 3 ou d'armes au 3 rue aux
quais lte va peut-être faire c4 mais il
aura perdu du temps il aura pourri sa
structure de pions le problème aussi ce
qu'il s'est exactement aller aux jo
pause
l'excellent hockey mais il peut exceller
autant qu'il veut si tu fais tu vas
faire le 4 et le truc en c3 emprise oui
moi j'ai vu qu est ce que tu peux faire
pousser 6 maintenant à temps et surtout
prend ses 3 nous propose d'argent 5 3 h
8 et f4 peut-être 24 je pense de la ddt
vous ces trois dames g5 ça et tour f 4
la mostra
il retrouvera quatre mêlées sûrement
oublié que ça tourne comme l'illustrent
alors même si elle viendrait bien rue
parce qu'ils avaient une enfilade et
avec 1 d'avancé cette e-menace d'un
monde meilleur il mène au temps qui
viennent nuire jonathan et rétribués au
cours de cette partie
mais notons d'ailleurs que vale h3 il
est bien passé pour ce qu'ils contrôlent
fdu si jamais il termine pas si pour
l'instant d'éléments il est toujours
prêt de d'accompagner la tacc défendre
ce qui est important il ya même des fous
processus qui s'entête envisageable pour
ramener la laddh à manger quoi oui
pourquoi pas comment les 2,5 pourquoi le
prof comme les 2,5 parce que je sais pas
valser trop compliqué pour moi est faux
de synchro à bouche fois oui 3 bougez
tour bouge tout prendre d'emblée cette
ma cavale et de sacs s'étaient locaux
une passion l'impasse y aura peut-être
quelque chose panon et rien narrateur ça
se voit qu'il ya deux rattachés à ces
super bien joué d'un v6 que là elle va
souffrir affrété le voit peut-être moins
pas souffrir parce que je souris
beaucoup
mais peut-être juste complètement foutue
l'un ok pour l'instant le cavalier
stopper l'action mais ok mais le
structure n'est pas bien et qui très
très désagréable plus il est pour voir
le milieu de terrain fidèle à son style
volet milieu de réfléchir à au lieu de
jouer si rapide parce que elle est
rentrée dans une finale qui est possible
de faire des choses avec les manques en
quelques coups maintenant risque moindre
ça risque de devenir un problème est-ce
que ça alarmant
non c'est pas encore alarmant je veux
dire quand ça va être alarmant j'espère
que j'aurai jamais le dire haut ce soir
mais c'est très désagréable parce que
c'est une finale que dont les gueules je
vais moins pas regardez donc ces trois
au québec un joueur très bon jeu élevé
aux jouets h3 et trottoirs donc les
noirs peut-être doivent fait j'ai vu sur
ces trois leviers ce que la science où
j'essaie tour des 3 et tour d un ça peut
être une idée pas ici en fait comment tu
joues de tels types l'opposition tout
est mauvais ici dans ce type de position
donc tout ce que tu fais tu essaies de
ne pas perdre tout de suite
donc en gros une manière de jouer de
telle finale
qu'est ce qu'on veut et tenter cavaliers
g6 et quand lé h 4 pour revenir attaqué
le pion et éventuellement faire cavalier
f3 tu vois les bouquets amer foot 7 foot
et 4 étaient très très bien joué moi qui
avait en fait sur ce petit relief de
jouer juste sacrifier quoi et essayer de
choper un pion non ok c'est compliquer
sinon ils menacent b5 au civil à na waie
la poisse leur colle mille fois que vous
les deux sens que tu es possible il n'a
pas fait ça une seule fois dans cette
affaire c'est pour ça qu'il voit quand
les six c'est d'ailleurs exactement ce
que t'a proposé non c'est mauvais signe
bah non je pense que vaut mieux un
mauvais coup qui donne de l'espoir même
opportuniste qui au juste bouger les
pièces en espoirs et l'idée c'était là
dessus de prendre prendre et faire
cavalier problème 5 ou peut-être comme
d'immortal vos maillots la fin horrible
kyo le rural forêt et c'est exactement
mon idée en fait quand j'ai proposé j'ai
vu cette fille
exact mais j'ai pensé que c'était
foutyou comme tu dis le problème c'est
le cavalier à 4 ok mais bouffé 6 quand
même qui sait pourquoi garder vivant ce
que vaut lire pendant si longtemps pour
pour rui perdition à 405 gloire même si
avouons que des milliers d'occasions de
documentaires sur 200 m le maudit face
au f 3 fou b5 et kee walk est inquiet
mais ok regarde c'est quand même pas si
mal d'avoir fait cette variante
puisqu'il a récupéré deux pions et des
louis et des pour jouer pour jouer trois
jeux de boules un à saint-claude
soutiennent dans ce cas là ya pas de
besoin urgent de nourriture jouets 3
jeux dofus un coin à ok j'avais un
tournant mais quand j'ai 8 ans j'ai vu
que je prends b6 mad avec le cavaly plus
de trois jeux d'eau après après tu as
encore plus l'âme écoute depuis qui suit
ce que je dis tout se passe beaucoup
mieux pas du plus que jo comme toi oui
enfin titulaire et je comme moi ça
aurait pu être encore plus beau du coup
ici joyent ne réussit pas à jouer au
meilleur niveau et quand même quoi je
suis l'un des deux mains qui commentent
en france est quoi ce prix ce pv nice
attend peut-être fou 1,4 à aulas ça fait
longtemps qu'on a pas vu des menaces de
la part de points de cette partie non
mais ok ne nous croyez ce cavalier en
fait il va finir par le croire a pas
autour des 4 ok tour des quatre coups dé
4,3 peut-être à elle veut que trois
fours 4
aulas
attends roule à l'auteur d'ailleurs à
oublier cette ressource là l'autre a
oublié de réussite 7 sur 7
ici il ya maintenant de chance pour
sauver les parties bref ce qui va
réussir à 3 - du matos et puis les
pièces brh son cinquième et tout reprend
b6 peut-être quand même non l'intérêt
pour jouer au foot ou cinq tours
bautista inquiéter tient à l'épreuve et
6 luis borges rythme ya tour h61 quoi à
3,6 tour d'un roi the dove 4 ok je vois
hockey à elle veut dire qu'après
tourache 4-2 rouages deuxième des
milliers de chèques mais pas facile de
trouver celui qui gagne il menace fond
du sac après qu elle ait mené 5-3
c'est très très très moche c'est
incroyable cette partie où il inquiet
mais il va réussir à s'échapper quoi ah
mais ça y est les milieux la cti des
cinq mannequins comme doute le mieux est
d'ailleurs aucune risque le 3è tour 5
ok pour ce 5 pour cette pratique mais
vas-y tourbe et si ça leur tombe et 6
tomber s'ils souhaitent aller plus vite
j'ai peur vlad est ok il est tombé fou
hockey de nouveau à égalité
pas facile quoi une odeur torture avec
le noir alors qu'est ce que c'est serré
qu'un match roy m
ok là cette fois ci je prévois que l'ont
répété les lignes mais après agathe la
règle et chic on va se mettre à
réfléchir a compris que peut-être si
tout n'est pas si facile il faut quand
même réfléchir qu'elle va réfléchir
maintenant pour des six jeux toujours
quoi ok mais elle est si content de ce
que les répéter
moi j'ai fait une position tellement
pourri quoi bousculer
d'ailleurs ici je pense que cette ds et
le où il faut crier la foule les
sauveteurs mais il a répété ça tellement
vite pas je vois aucune raison pour
faire ce à quoi je pense que cette
journée ton ami au pour les bourgs et
vlad petite information importante c'est
la dernière partie normalement 5
puissant de way et à cause d'un bug
technique le chronomètre qu'on a
c'est pas un chronomètre officielle donc
je suis pas sûr à quelque chose qu'ils
voient pas ok et donc de fait dans ce 4
ok cette fois ci il fait gaffe à la
colonne a et donc ils veulent juste
faire ok 25e les schistes que les
dessins oui comme dans la précédente
ou peut-être h six mois maintenant elle
sait qu'il ya par deux à part de la
colonne à à part de rémunérer au volet
sur f5 les bois n'ont pas trop d'aidés
en fait pas trop quoi
d'ailleurs je tiens à souligner que -
mais la partie précédente avec le doigt
à part un moment donné gris choc aurait
pu au juste dans ses news
en prenant le plus haut sur cintres mais
finalement c'est marrant parce que quand
tu regarde la physionomie du match l'a
jusqu'ici la partie précédente great
choc aurait pas dû perdre il a perdu
c'est des fois des décisions un peu
comment dire non celle de l'aisne c'est
différent mais des décisions peu
impulsif qui font perdre les joueurs ça
se joue à pas grand chose
oui mais ce qui est incroyable que sa
décision horrible de rentrer dans la
dolce et yann de rentrer dans les
finales
tu te rappelles quand elle a permis le
change de date oui à en croire que ces
décisions mais qui les ramenait le voyez
maintenant
maintenant il y en est en train de
montrer une 3e ou 2e position
c'est de mettre son pion sur des 4 et
jouait sa de la manière comment dire
qu'albi dame carol ann tarrach la cram
ni que un plus gros field - enfin jouer
sur sur le laisse passer le pion sait
sauf qu'ici en france et 4 il faut
toujours se souvenir de quelques coups
bas mot 4 même si peut-être ans à dorian
d'invocateur ok mais je dois dire que je
préfère les bois aussi je pense pas que
c'est une égalisation pur et dur je
préfère les bornes et je pense
que va faire donne aux gros je n'aime
pas trop cette façon de traiter
prêté cette ligne avec eux comment ça
commence à 6 petites questions
techniques à 3 minutes de pause après ça
tu as été mal dans cinq parties avec les
noirs côté gris juke qu'est ce que tu
fais pendant les trois minutes
ben tu vois j'ai vu ton ordi quoi moi je
sais pas si c'est permis par les règles
non je pense que ces permis de se coller
toile de jute fêlures tire d'ailleurs
pour un bon mot qui a toujours le redis
à lui mais regardez les trucs vital ça
prend moins de mme enos il suffit je
crois 45 52 minutes donc c'est le
conseil que tu donnes un gris tout cas
moi il faut absolument éviter ça pour
n'ai pas regardé de telle pions b qui
vont ces dames 1 à l'instar de pions des
degrés choc avec lebron saint-etienne
qui m'a forcé de relâcher rien que voir
ça
mais j'ai pensé pire là dessus pour
c'est à dire c'est ça qui m'a poussé à
stopper les échecs détection des vieux à
ok mais si c'est les charges de date
pour cette eau-là la théorie très très
très typique en tant que leader dans le
groupe une fois les fonds sur cette voie
là c'est fini tu penses toi 8 f 5
je sais pas moi même si c'est peut-être
ça sauve même mais ok ok sauf que ok
bien sûr ça sauve pas parce que ce n'est
que ce n'est qu'ils ont une femme à
l'horrible ne peut pas être
objectivement nul ce truc là
une fois les bois vont arriver sur avec
le roi sur c4 se foutent ue mais qu'est
ce que les noirs peut vous faire contre
ça je sais pas
khemissi à quelqu'un qui trouve ses
grilles ou qu il est bien pour cela elle
est très bien pour cela mais quelque
chose doit être fait avec la couleur
noire parce que c'est ok je suppose
avant ok mais c'est fou tout ça pour
bosser tout ce que tu veux tout ce que
tu attends attends attends attends s'il
fait tomber ça tu joues comment ou de
caprins ce que sur tomber ça il voulait
faire pousser 5 même ça c'est dur mais
ok c'est jouable mais oui ici ce foutu
juste avec les fausses fruits le pionner
bien trop fort la tour est bien trop
mauvais sur 17 et tout horrible ok roi
ces quatre groupes de quatre avec les
défauts 5 avec de tels payons maintenant
allez les gones sont gagnants même dans
les finales de plus de 4 c'est bien joué
et lui au moins essayer de changer les
emprunts c'est quoi ces 6 arrive trop
vite
ah ok peut-être son idée non je vous
dire ce roi ces six tours décisifs
prendront b6 faire food et qui fout des
400 m2 mais ça va pas suffire non mot
sur foncier soit deux tours de 6 300
jeunes jouteurs de cette eau qui monte
au mois en cours comment es tu veux
faire parce que les noirs veut le faire
je f4 et s'amplifier tout ce qui est
populaire mais les questions est ce que
nous assène je sais pas les réponses que
le problème c'est que les noirs n'ont
pas réussi de m le roi sur deux sets ça
le problème
je les fais 3 8 mai avoir un problème
mais là il va pas tout est changé et
qu'on assure g3 wave 3 je peux des
hoquets normalement avant je suis pas
spécialiste de telle finale ouais je
suis très loin d'être spécialiste
vous êtes un moment donné tu fais
fujitsu g53 e63 machin et tu chopes le
pion quoi ok ménagers de i phone week et
il faut quoi il faut mettre le coup sûr
je sens qu assure sanquer attendre
l'astuce dans ces cas-là ça parce que
quand tu feras g2 et le fousseret ou 3
tu feras géant dames france j10 f4 et là
je pense plutôt terrain tout ariane est
devenu foulée alors je pense que non ça
va aller ça maintenant mais qu'est ce
que lebron pourvoi faire contre je dors
au f5 info je sais pas ce que fait nul
ok les fous des six aéronefs 5
maintenant euro à 2,5
c'est fini bond incroyable incroyable et
kill kill kill kill koutchma
ok j'y reviens tout de suite ok alors
mais incroyable en ce début de match
cela de fantastique je remets un lien
dans le chat si jamais vous voulez
partager
je vais je vais remettre le lien pour
reha plus de parties d'échecs 960 cette
année puisqu'ils ont voulu réduire la
durée des matches est donc ils ont viré
les 960 ils ont viré ce qui était le
moins compréhensible entre guillemets
pour le public et du coup pas si vous
qui fait de match parce que c'est
vraiment le meilleur match qu'on a pu le
début de l'année vous pouvez partager
sur facebook
quatre et demi quatre et demi serré
comme pas possible et à la différence du
match contre dominguez mvl vous sentez
calvel le passerai en bullet à la cette
fois ci ça me paraît plus chaud et je
suis un petit peu déçu au niveau des
partages parce qu'on a que 8 partage
c'est ridiculement peu pour le nombre de
faux on a parlé les mecs franchement ça
craint quand on est 500 que huit partage
pour un match comme ça avec en plus l
femmes aux malades aux commentaires je
sais pas peut-être que vous n'aimez pas
les échecs en réalité j'en sais rien moi
mais ça craint les mecs ça craint sacre
c'est vraiment un très très beau match
du patient la famille vit dans le chat
qui peut nous confirmer sa l'avis du
spécialiste wafou
parmi eux quelle excuse n'est pas
facebook mes amis ne joue pas aux échecs
et tout ça ça ne compte pas quoi je ne
prends plus ses excuses
si vous avez twitter aussi peut-être
salut à sa place vous avez aussi twitter
vous avez de tout quoi twitter ya que 3
retweet fin je passe sur 500 personnes y
a on a onze personnes qui ont twitté
facebook vous me faites peur que cela
change il est peut-être un peu trop dans
la soirée pour voir du monde
on est quand même pas mal de monde 1500
personnes c'est quand même pas mal pour
un truc d'échec c'est bien c'est mieux
que le grand duché sourds toujours bien
si on n'a pas de joueurs français ce
soir donc c'est un petit peu dur c'est
pour ça qu'on a besoin de votre aide les
mecs on a besoin de votre aide
mais on est plus que les russes ça c'est
bien attendez je vais choquer mon
téléphone ce que je reçois des sms sur
les mecs j'arrive je cherche mon
téléphone je sais pas où il est
j'arrive pas à mettre la main dessus ça
y est je l'aï attrapée au key affable
qui m'envoient des sms il est là sans
être là femme qui avait qui n'a plus son
mot de passe
bah je sais pas bateau afab bats toi
comme tu peux pour refaire un conte quoi
fin nous avons besoin de toi dans le
tchat
je renvoie le lien facebook ceux qui
n'ont pas eu loin twitter on va faire ce
qu'on peut mais c'est cool c'est cool
c'est cool vous suivez quand même on est
plus que nos amis que nos amis russes
donc c'est cool c'est qu'un petit sms je
suis là y'a blatt qui est en train de
revenir je l'entends salle où je suis un
bac
bah c'est cool on et 580 laddh les
russes sont 160 donc il ya plus de gens
qui nous suivent que le truc russe faut
le savoir n'est tana convient part donc
en et 580 c'est cool on est nombreux
ça va très bien bon égalité à présent pl
ils vont maintenant commencer avec ses
chers jeu s'opposerait non y'a plus
fischer cette année donc pourquoi c'est
pas parce qu car ce n'était pas bon
d'aller d'algérie non en fait
karl scène je tiens de vous souligner
que l'hommage que hélas dans lequel il a
écrasé sacha il a perdu toutes les trois
parties de boeuf et celle là mais il
joue pas cette année car en scène c'est
juste qu'ils ont voulu réduire le temps
de jeu et du coup on attend l info juste
que j'aille choper le temps on va
renaître le temps d'ailleurs vlad j'ai
failli te recommander pour les
commentaires en russe des speechs s mais
j'ai décidé de pas faire de manière très
égoïste tiens d'ailleurs je pense que
j'ai une même génération préface hilde
pour grey xiu précis ils répètent leurs
parties précédentes - voyage va pas
répéter et va essayer tous les couilles
il voit que même s'il est pas bien ils
se débrouillent mieux la déposition de
résultats tout baignant dans les
positions il peut y avoir un résultat
positif ou négatif quoi victoire ou
défaite
il a beaucoup plus d'expérience dans ses
positions bizarres et c'est pour ça que
le tien de les répéter parce que si tu
as lu l'ordinateur il voit toujours
donné l'avantagé à bois aux branches
mais c'est loin d'être recouvert en fait
par exemple jamais le pion sur f7 les
besoins sont nettement mieux si elle met
le pion sur f5 ce n'est pas claire parce
que le noir contre le capot c'est long
de différentes centrales est indienne et
les structures est-à-dire les la
structure hollandaise d'atg d'échouer
ok oui il y avait une partie excellente
gagné par fortiche en 99 90 compteur jeu
plus qui peut-être contre mourinho
qu'avec eux exactement les mêmes pièces
sur l'échiquier
moi je pense qu objectivement sais c'est
pas un grand chose pour les bons même si
je préfère les bons toujours en feu
est-ce que j'habite est ce que j'ai vu
une dame me ndiaye ballet national donc
il tient le livre les il tient les îles
il il il vise les fagots est ce que je
peux te choquer en te disant qu'est une
belle partie de shirov contre bas relief
dans une hollandaise non tu vois pas me
choque et bien sûr mais c'était de notre
cette partie est jouée de nos co2
moyennes traitement différent mais ça
n'a aucun rapport
n'hésitez pour te choquer je connais une
partie quoi ok la position des gains au
québec justement pour prouver ce que je
viens de dire avant les branches pensons
toujours un peu mieux après l'ouverture
de leur parti mais après ils se
débrouillent mieux d'aller finesse
résultante parce que les rockies les
finales objectivement c'est rien du tout
ça est ce qu on lire dans le chat les
gens se demandent si le vla d'angers 2
va réussir à briller dans cette partie
l'oeuvre est junior de vlad junior
ballet ya pas de là dedans cette
position quoi mais le problème c'est que
le petit yann sur quatre pans mauvais
non plus voir il est pas mauvais henri
iv
parce qu ils neutralisent
le junior là il faut échanger jeu vlad
contrôle riham quaremont en donner alors
maintenant je pense que sénégalais
devront se changer partir boire les
biens ou la vodka
ça fait très longtemps que le seigneur
ne bois plus de votre corps save ladhuie
niort celle ci finit quoi donc qu'est ce
que tu fais mon cher ami turbo 2 ou bout
ça vous aurait fait tomber deux je pense
moi qui ai la mahatma 6-1 et cynique un
peu joué oui vraiment fait durer
peut-être bouffer en vue 4 avant
j'aurais eu peur de cavaliers c3 mais
qu'elle sait travail a baissé
miami a b c & a bossé ouais moi turbo et
c'est tout à fait jouable je suppose de
0 à 6 heures
quoique après tours 5
ben non ok je pense pas à l'euro à noah
rétroactif à my f3 f4 1 c'est pas mal ça
prise prix f3 déplace le fou ça et f4
échec
qu'est ce que gagne la qualité donc
baissé sa vitre le dépôt c'est tubuai où
mona tout racisme de raciste et si leur
prix baisser avant avril il est vrai à
3,5
ok pains surprises que ça a été bien
joué par ian je pense que si tous voient
dans la direction correcte je pense que
ça vaut savoir être nul à temps et ici
j'ai une idée
non mais ça va pas je voulais essayer
ces cinq est passé sur la colonne des
mais ça va pas marcher je pense ok c'est
ce qui fait mais avoir marché mais ça va
pas donner davantage sa valise et un
moment donné je porte à faux avant
j'avais pas vu donc et gris tout cas
refusé la nulle mais je pense que c'est
parce qu'il ya hockey il propose
maintenant est ok ok oui bien sûr
ok toujours insatisfait des des
résultats dans l'ouverture
une fois j'en joue plus et la grande
base de données espagnole cédée sur cd
sur glane ah oui on a bien su analyser
ça avec toi qui c'était clair mais en
fait c'est pour ça qu'il a changé il a
dû se dire que j'allais revenir quand il
saurait quoi c'est toujours
questionnable ou matériaux cavalière sur
le sens que je pense pas sûr que cette
possible moi bowie très intéressant
parce que la couleur collées sur 2,7
il est potentiellement très près actif
sur ce sens qu'il est placé très
harmonieux a trait à nos harmonieusement
pense que i still dunois c'est sûr que
les noirs douar votre bille en apothéose
u23 franchi ce jeu mais dans ce cas les
destins d'un fusil 6 à la forêt mais
peut-être cavaler h4 est sûr qu'avec des
singes en écaille projet 6 mai a mis le
dg ray dame aux 6es à il ya même pas
l'aider parce qu'il est tout à fait d'un
tour et cruel à non mais là maintenant
ça va être un problème pour yann invoqué
menaces cavaliers dessin qui menacent
cavaliers ces cinq cavaliers pros 24
aussi parce que le pion tu vas pas
pouvoir protéger à force parce que si
dans ce cas terry yake valises lui
paraît oui oui tiens ça commence
pourquoi parce que le pion sur quatre
c'est pas que le plan se recadrent ce we
still here ou quand le virer vous donne
quoi non mais ce que j'aime bien
enfin je comprends vers l'idée de sacha
l'idée de sacha il s'est dit je vais
aller voir ma base de données pendant la
pause et je vais essayer de tenir en
changeant de route
et on le punissant après est-ce que
c'était une bonne stratégie
je sais pas je gagne en entendant jeu
sauf mêmes gagne parfois des finales
foutu intéressant intéressant peut-être
que le match en train de tourner non
mais c'est intéressant que les joueurs
ont eu des problèmes avec les noirs en
début de match et les deux ont réglé
leur problème
yann avec le landaise et gris duke avec
la pause mais ok effacé un pion ça tient
très pratiques comme la décision très
pratique on guette décision qui met fois
un cavalier f4 maintenant et son idée c
est très simple juste donner le plus
haut ne continue de jouer comme quoi
rien ne s'est passé quand les six
collèges quatre attentats faisait froid
ok oui
et maintenant tout est recalé en quatre
au prochain pour préparer car les jeux
si ce que valait ce cadre d'une fois
elle va bouffer le fou sur justice
maîtres sont collés sur ces quatre là
comme la compensation va être bon
maintenant c'est un moment très très
important il faut bien réfléchir pour ne
pas donner aux bonne compensation et je
ne sais pas si dame au stade un bon coup
mais je vois très bien pourquoi demos
est élevé les îles voulez vous mettre sa
dame sur futures ou sur ces cinq
peut-être aussi sur ce sens qu aussi
ouais ok le test d'âmes c5 maintenant ça
me ressemble à une gaffe garde jusqu'au
24 et tiennent une fois il n'a pas
obtenu ce qu il les a voulu obtenir et
les uns peut-il télé parce que d'abord
il a sacrifié le pion c'était correct je
pense mais c'était pas les pointes de
donner les clés en plus n'oublie pas que
maintenant m6 arrivé dès que tu fais ici
c'est fini ok maintenant elle va jouer
tour quatre fours 4e volet au sein comme
espérance qu on le sent que le sens
qu'il faut se mettre quelque part mme se
doit
si oui mais quoi d'autre
quoi d'autre parce que cavalier bruit ce
week-end au centre comme le 5 2006 adam
g iii je voyais adore je crois
ok y'a change pas il est toujours fidèle
à ses c'est ok mais je fais dams et s'en
est peut-être là ok je vais faire
d'incessants cadastre et demi donc je
trouve apparaît même et je veux faire
baisser de faits réels épisode
maintenant ce qui au pourquoi pas jouer
tour de et juste qu'est ce que tu veux
qu'on valait de cet investisseur non
regardez cette dame prend b2 à part donc
en laisse et quatre cas d'investissement
je m'excuse je m'excuse quand vous voyez
je vois toujours rien donc pas la pointe
pour moi de jouer aux échecs
non tu préfères dominé les échecs
mondiaux tj a pour deux oui tour de huit
cavaliers c6
ce qui est important et d'amour 2 wii ou
d'approuver deux marchés aussi mais
c'est vrai j'aimerais tour des deux
tours des deux tours d2 d'ailleurs il ya
aussi des modes doux tout doux tout doux
rêve du retour de 2,6 tour deux tours
bordeaux turbo 2 sur 5 oui l'armée qui
me tournait des directs plus simple oui
mais juste si tu veux pour son client un
e hôte sse et comme les opérateurs c'est
vraiment un papy quoi ok non mais du
coup est risqué avec le noir est-ce que
tu considères que tu joues plus aux
échecs mais que tu chapote les échecs
tels un marionnettiste quoi le mot
marie-reine autistes j'aime pas que le
répète toujours parce qu'il est
tellement pas convaincant dans cette
souriante que je pense pas que c'est la
peine de répéter la non mais du coup je
sais quoi est né à cavaler 2,5 mais
pourquoi pas tour slam avec l'idée que
relais de ce qui l'attend la pause avant
le but mais il voit de nouveau pour
cette position mais elle est presque pas
mieux pour les bons en feu au caire où
il faut commencer avec dans ces deux
livres et que vous laissez aux 4 et
coller de 5 le fameux ou pas ou toujours
pas quand les deux sens que les cas
terme ok ça donne rien
cette tour bouge non non c'est pas ça
n'a pas du tout sa préparation sur le
landais ça va pas du tout la diva foire
puis tu corriges ça dans les semaines à
venir
sauf que à san luis sandri personne qui
sait quoi peut-être après ce match et
tout le monde va faire sans que ces
pressions peut-être ces opportunistes
comme le 2 parce que si je sens que l
étiquette sinon que les catastrophes
donc il va faire dame aussi trois sets
mais je suis pas sûr en tête on veut
faire h4 est menacée crois que c'est un
trou de quelqu'un qui vient de perdre
une partie d'ailleurs tiens cavale et
quatre tours bouge est fou et 6 qui
viennent mais elle a raté un anneau
d'amour qui n'en fait pas assez
4la avec les mots justes parce que blitz
souvent même pas grand mais au lieu au
lieu de bessengue voulait faire h4 et je
menaçais froid lecavalier avait plus
case c'était quand même violent comme
menace non mais il veut comme quoi crier
info blessure c'est cissé il crée les
faiblesses pour nous mêmes et il pense
que ceci soit être plus sensible surtout
vu la cadence
parce que les noirs ou la case ce 5 mai
y a rien quoi attaquer sur ce circuit il
ya eu six voitures va être amer
lorsqu'il les deux sirops noisette note
par contre je pense pas que je serais
permis h 4 en fait juste du bruit comme
un jour dégoûté h4h des postes parce que
c'est vraiment facile de ternate après
quoi je pense qu'après cette partie il
va s'arrêter de jouer ce serait de faire
cette variante cette souriante avec le
bois il va peut-être la perdre là parce
qu'il ya aussi d'un machisme d'un match
2 qui arrive maintenant vlad
c'est horrible comme on joue soit ici
j'ai perdu plein de fois des partis
comme ça et depuis je joue mieux j'ai
encore regardé et tout ça appartient
juste pas cette position là mais le
problème c'est qu'il faudrait qu'ils
aient le temps de faire flouer trois
rois j'ai dit je pense que peut-être il
va sacrifier la dame kovalev qatar
d'embûches
3 pour faire vous prend et guerroient g2
laddh comment il a fait fouet 3 c'est
pas mal joué je pense mais maintenant
rage et deux femmes et trois jeunes et
on prend 1,3 mesdames prendrait six
peut-être non mais quand voilées ou et
heurtoir d'anne decis tôt trois en lice
ok y'a rien de grave non mais j'ai
vraiment passé du temps à analyser ce
truc là après avoir perdu beaucoup de
partis et si tu mets ce set up et un
tour h 1 qui arrive ça va en fait oui
kovalev qatar est possible s'ils jouent
sur je sens qu'il ya même un coût que
roulers en colère cinq projets et après
il ya ça qui tombe il ya quoi
il ya un retour qui tombe à la fin oui
ou le courrier sur 5 ou le clos sur 101
peut-être elle était une petite faute de
départ de yan a été d'essayer de monter
tout doucement puis il a fallu regarder
cette ce motif duo matt sur le canot h
pour plus tard oui parce que moi tu n'as
qu'à moi mais les facile de jouer avec
les bons d'ailleurs plutôt terral si ça
a été encore plus intéressant que ça
donc je ne sais pas à quelle envie
d'encaisser le pion aux flammes comme
les autres à coeur de réussir parce
qu'il va mieux si c'est qu'il veut
qu'après que voient les u6 tam g6
j'imagine et se parlent moins tu défends
ton plongerait 5 quand même parce que
super g 5 et le truc en fout.ce s'ils
s'opposent m'en fous c'est si différent
ça marche mais c'est bordélique un vieux
quatre fosses aussi ce que le locateur
fait huit tours 8
tiens ça c'est beau ça ça c'est pas mal
avec les deux cas valeo 4 ap 04 04
je vois qu'ils commencent de terre plus
chaud qu'avant car enfin je l'espère sg
créateur maintenant en herbe
je quitterai ce qui est fou c'est si ces
prédicateurs tour c'est ce que relève
quatre dames je sais très vite que le
vidame deux sets car les 1,5 ou l'ailé
[ __ ] mais d'emprunt 8 à la fin oui
peut-être les deux mais oui f4 c'est
très bizarre parce qu'avec ce propos mme
ans il est tous ces dernières se
démenant c'est bizarre en plus j'ai
capté très heureux de castres il m'a les
noirs ne sont plus bien et sur l'idée ça
a été de dégager le faut à un moment
donné sans trop calculer magic à des
processus
il est tout aussi joué à 14,4 après quoi
même positionnement et les mauvais parce
que c'est qu'on va lire donc le cas ça
peut être un premier break la digue
riccio gagne c'est le premier break du
match c'est la première fois qu'un des
deux joueurs sera plus de vlad
il n'y a pas eu de plus de encore 05 10
sur le chat anglophone jeudi sacha let's
go let's go je sers de faire des trucs
des ramières à vrai dire je vois pas
trop court quand les fenêtres qui enlève
ses gains directs non bah oui quoi
et d'ailleurs la chose le plus évident
pour voir même moi j'aurais vu rift sept
collèges du canada
ok mais ça va pas bien loin sinon
peut-être juste tour géant la tranquille
qu'est ce que par un collège de cinq
enfants dans les rouages encore les 3a
[ __ ] mais il ya perpète la noël et
perdu les plasmides a perdu la pièce
carrément ok mais attend il incombe
boîte de la piège
ok maintenant 5,5 fois ci c'est ça que
tu youyou d'ailleurs parce que l'euro le
crevale ait su réformer mois le placer
et les pulsions à il va partir feller et
en plus tu peux pas des clous en un coup
histoire de cette dure de cette arrivée
troisième
moi je sais trop à jaro f6 ok mais fou
prend f7 et tourner ces chèques
bien bien bien tu vois bien de choses
mieux que moi d'heure inquiet mais
demain je joue contre cannes ce qu'ils
veulent
il faut que je suis pas champion ce qui
n'est plus comment s'appelle n'est plus
un complément
ok ça va terminer le tour de cette tour
à cet achat mais il aurait pu jouer
autour de six lycées kiev hockey en moi
qui m'ont choqué me tomberait pas une
seule pièce comme ça quoi
une seule pièce quoi années il était dur
interne une fois il suffit de jouer ça
correctement une seule fois le taux de
change tout de suite l'ouverture mais il
est parti dans l'italienne il a raison
oui maintenant les questionne qui est ce
que yann à préparer contre les lits qui
[Applaudissements]
hausse à chaab a joué contre avril à
tbilissi il est perdu le match à cause
de lingway les lignes les que les
correct
est ce que dans des huit damas est c'est
une idée ici souvent mais plutôt pas
avec le plus on sera 4 parce que quand
tu joues dans vos 8 à part de l'est de
damas et à l'idée de jouer bourrin et
site a qu un seul but ok à vrai dire je
me souviens de rien je sais juste que ce
doit être plus ou moins correct mais
tout le monde ne s'en fout parce que
c'est pas ça le plus important
l'important c'est de se voir bien jouer
cette position là maintenant donc le
pion va être amenés un jour pour cette
les besoins pur peter brook
parce que la dame de plus gros qui est
après tout rêve bri donc maintenant
sacha doit réfléchir bouge le préciser
après il va faire tours fc tours 6 plus
peut-être parce que tous rêvent 6 il ya
quand les h2k les 4,6 là on revient on
empêche kg 4 pouces et d'emile ward
déplacent leurs bandes sur justice
enfin c'est très bizarre ce type de pose
quand les besoins ou leurs pions sur à 5
et
4 l'ordinateur pense que lebron somillau
car les pions sont comme ça maintenant
d'ordinateurs pense que c'est égal parce
que le choix pour les oiseaux pour céder
4 mai après le décès d les noirs ou les
4 4 mais je me suis bien expliqué ando
mort c'est quoi la les problématiques
positionner tu as eu le kiosque sûrs à
100 km a pourtant fait une longue de
subtiles et dit qu'il faut se voir
opposer et tu veux pas échanger et faire
tous rêvent six tours et fuites n'ont
échangé les tours quand le pion voix sur
g4 c'est toujours très dangereux pour
celui de c'est bien trop profond dans
mon goût à vrai dire est ce que tu
comprend du coup tout cela mais je
comprends rien à laval c'est ce qu' ils
pensent que les parties vont être durs
et 60 18 coups et donc qu'il pense qu'il
faut surtout joué les vedettes qui veut
ça tours on s'est vite pour libérer sa
dame est arrivée rage 5 avec la dame oui
juste moi je sors elvio donc réaliser ce
que dont je suis pas je parle est décédé
mais maintenant pour faire 1 6 2 sans
que vos les bobcats et alors donc c'est
le temps le truc des pions dont kim et
moi même un toit était intéressant il a
joué très vite le tour et froid était
très intéressant pour échanger les tours
en cours je l'amène à réfléchir sans
réfléchir je sais à quoi tu penses g5
très bien joué ou la tempête chef 4 et
tu fixes - qui en fait se dégage tu peux
faire pas mal de choses tu peux faire
est ce que je qualifie les laisser faire
choquée qu'il lsf calade nous auraient
jamais laisser ça ils ont commencé de
jeu hyper pratique que de risquer à eux
deux qu'est ce qu'ils font
ce week end il faut dire qu'à moins que
le roi bwana sefu parce que pour pouvoir
louer qu'acheter ils feront cour entame
avec h4d peut-être joué g5 directement
tout être même jeu cinq directeurs ce
qui est champion de france
moi même sens à 6 en charge les tours -
l'euro est faible c'est ça le thème tour
5 sur 5 tours 8
est ce que tu veux dire qu'il a
peut-être il est pour nous et troy davis
est ce que tu veux pas jouer pour le
ghana tenant bon comme quoi je pense que
les embête pas comme un match 5
moi j'aime pas cette position là tu
quand même arrête h 55
oui il est vrai que le problème c'est
qu'il voit il veut peut-être pas échangé
la tour sur 5 parce que dans ce cas là
et les bois ou pour organiser le plus
ont passé sur cinq
non mais je pense qu'il a très mal joué
peut-être ferdane des ans maintenant
avec l'idée tour des deux dames h1
peut-être un voileux fera prêter russie
mais vrai toi aussi tu sais pas
peut-être le verband et 5 après tout
reste ici s'il peut faire dame de cinglé
plusieurs doigts de roche 3 d'un machin
qu'est cette manne en d1 ou d2 dame bien
moi qui ai fait comme ça si je damer le
pion de trois entreprises aussi malgré
que yann doit prendre là nul effet
retour et 8
très pratique
comme je vous ai dit mille fois la jeune
génération et r 1000 fois plus pratique
que leur génération
mille fois n'importe qu'ils gagnent ou
même pays est mille fois plus pratiqué
au incertaine et voyous payent
elle sait bien jouer vers l'après en
quoi elles ont encore des news ou quoi
non non on y réfléchit mian le savons
être dur de jeu pour gagner après h55 et
il a proposé
ok ça va un moment donné ça m'a pas plu
trouve peut-être le terrain c'est trop
dépêché avec cinq ans
ouais mais bon est ce qui pouvait
vraiment faire mieux a aussi regardé sa
base de données qu'est-ce qui pouvait
vraiment faire mieux vlad
ah oui à voir il a joué déjà cavaliers
de sept mois après petit rock food comme
les poussettes
il avait une telle partie week et bien
sûr c'est pas prendre ces points bien
sûr ce n'est que pour éviter de grosses
lignes
ce doit être pas trop bien est juste je
jouais rapide et entreprenant yakine tu
poses une question intéressante si nous
demande qui est le second dans deux
dépôts maintenant je sais pas avant
cette protéine maintenant je sais plus
tiens il notre greenfield aviez campion
du moins pour les bois n'ya point des
grandes villes de ce type je sais pas
comment évoluer sous lula
je sais que les bons toujours au point
de compensation - à quel point occupe
maintenant il est très tentant de jouer
ce cadre de 5 bien sûr mais enfin bon il
veut pas c'est trop casser la tête de
jouer l'euro à chaque fois mais c'est
marrant parce que les étudiants ne sont
que - ya deux temples hindous pratiques
et mieux il joue quelques pas ah oui
mais c'est pour ça qu'il est toujours un
set up parce qu'il veut créer cette
situation là parce qu'il devient très
pratique et il joue de manière très
direct et très bien là peut-être juste
cavaliers g5 tu veux revenir vers 4 et
la dame arrivant j'ai 4 était bien quoi
normalement elle est dangereux quand
elle attaque parce que n'oublions pas il
a commencé en tant qu' un joueur d'attac
avec les bois lorsqu'il avait 16 ans les
jouets ou quatre attaques anglaises
abandon vont routière les ja core i7 920
francs
damas 7 à 8 et le plus haut sur beauxis
est défendu et si dans votre 3e volet
fit moins dans ce cas là est le cube
british motor des fonds de la mme13
direct les plus forts ok 500 n'est que
une gare de la part de
il ya maintenant je suppose que les deux
sont bien mais bien sûr damage 3 x 4 a
été possible si madame ausculte 3 bien
sûr beaucoup plus agressif parce qu'il
ya évidemment s'interroger si ce n'est
maintenant là c'est une tour ouais ok ça
sente le titre complet ou et qui est le
seul en conviant ce qui on en peut pas
jouer dans moi je crois parce que tours
de 12
donc il faut père en temps pour jouer
d'amodio dans les trois mois des
cultures de plus bien sûr un peu ce
qu'elle m'aime mais vous dites oh tu
sais que j'aurai pas sûr de bastia n'en
dans cette position - personnes
assistent voilà il commençait comme la
justice dans ceux ci se sont soulevés
retour des banques sont donc moins pour
quatre appareils wi fi et le temps est
arrivé pour abandonner après quoi dans
le cache de 4 appareils mais là ça va
envoyer du sist et toul 1924 à paris
donc voilà lié à la france va route
l'add on tient peut-être notre premier
break oui si c'est pas le breakbeat
marcilio donc je sais pas un peu plus
parier sur l'internet
d'ailleurs le prochain match 6 qualifie
ça risque d'être cariat qui ne se sera
un autre morceau vlad je pense que car
yakine sera favori face à gries ciocan
qualification pour le prochain tour
bon on va voir mais de toute manière il
est bien trop tôt d'en parler parce qu
équipe
merci ça fait plus d'aucun grand chose
en 36 mois ci a rien à calculer ça
marche bien sûr il s'est déjà fait
dix nations avec les deux dames quelque
part sur le deuxième tour ben non je
pense que ces idées ces dames f5 j'ai
quatre ans ferme là tu les fais un pas
mais j'ai quatre dames 2 3 et vous
choisissez selon votre goût
dans 2 3 ou 12 heures qu'elle commence
par tour d'air vraiment l'un fermé ok
mais peut-être c'est au bord des
terrains correct quand même de jeu ça
d'ailleurs il n'a par exemple pas ce que
toute manière elle va perdre mais comme
ça il diminue le nombre qui est
peut-être c4 fou prend ses quatre pour
des huit échecs et cavaliers aussi ce
bouquin venus assister reste finalement
au caire - est-ce qu'il y en a jamais
fait mieux dans les griffes et vous
voulez rire du tout peut-être qu'il y en
a une ou ils avaient plus ou moins
maquin ailleurs après l'italienne après
l'espagnol d'ailleurs elle n'a jamais
sortie l'écossais et l'écossaise
peut-être il va faire un qte dans les
bullet donc ces quatre c'est quand même
son douzième arme principale mais là on
est en diane ladd rien de spécial ce qui
est particulièrement agréable parce que
c'est une voiture préférée depuis
toujours
l'enfance l'enfant je pense que c'est
l'ouverture préféré de beaucoup de monde
ben laden indienne ça donne souvent des
partis à agressif tout le monde je
préfère me pabobo pas beaucoup d'humour
de les jouer à cause de la peur
peut-être cgppa monica bellucci et la
femme préférée de tout le monde mais on
n'est pas nombreux sur les courageux qui
vont s'approcher d'elle
nous avions vraiment essayé quoi on peut
comme avaient cru en moi par exemple je
pense elle non plus tut essaye de
rassurer comme ça rien la dernière ligne
twitter n'était pas nécessaire jean toi
t'as pas essayer ll t'as même pas noté
a3 moteur à toi maintenant sans aucun
doute les blancs vont jouer dans ce 2 à
brides en bo2
après quoi j'ai pas tout bout la je
pense
est ce qu'une fois les noirs aux jeux à
3 normalement je pense que les noirs
sont toujours bien mais il se demande
pour qui est peut-être pourquoi faire
peut-être pourquoi pas [ __ ] de cette
élite le décès de cette db5 mais après
ce délai blanc souvent joue pas demain
ed c'est encore pierrick simple add mono
parce que tu rick mois serait présent
aucun intérêt parce que les bons ne sont
pas trop bien enfin pas davantage je dis
pas que les noirs sont mis juste pas
davantage parce que bien sûr c'est en
rêve ou d'obtenir sa avec les noirs
importe qui joue le sanguine le
comprends moins bienveillants et on peut
pas dire que les branches sont faits on
fait quoi que ce soit de criminels est
ce que tu penses qu'il peut y avoir une
chanson comme ça il ya lysiane manga
indiana
oui oui oui
ces deals d'être expliquées les vieux et
les noirs vieux fou ce 5ème chef de
centre justice où elle gérait tout
risque at oui oui ça se voit qu'ils ont
leurs canettes des lignes principales de
lestienne et l'autre pas trop quoi
whaou sont foutus à sion
surtout il faut pas prendre des relais
tour si je prends la torah du cavalier a
quatre qui vont arriver à la grande île
ça sourire dame g5 d'un match 4 food et
4 août ou de l'aigle et faut jouer vite
j'ai pas un truc autour à chambre dans
bouge dans beauf wife doute qu'ils aient
continué à jouer à la wii voilà il a
fait ça avec lui autour du cou et
maintenant bond à mort si je soupe
hommage en effet camani f6 pour menacer
il mènera vers karim à ce titre en
quatre tours 4-1 mais pour l'instant
j'ai noir ou non si on peut parler des
problèmes noir un petit problème c'est
que l'offensé huit participants ont
couru la torah web participent
parfaitement tous les autres similaires
le fossé où il participa pour l'instant
pas encore si tu es un peu énervant mais
bien sûr il ya pas mal de trucs tactique
qui sont d'ailleurs maintenant je passe
deux tours f3 photo adamov 4
à chaque fois il faut prendre en compte
de telle possibilité
peut-être tour h4 comment dire comme les
jeunes générations
c'est cynique pratique moitié réaliste
tout ce qu'on aime quoi je cours parce
que en ce sens pour que la tour qui
défend le roi blanc - en échange le lot
foot couleur au noir qui défend le droit
encore plus quoi qu'ils se foutent y eut
bien sûr même failli en essayant mama
mama 4 à huy ce que je comprends ce
qu'il veut dire ils viennent échanger le
tour et bien bouger le pion aussi vite
que possible à 104 à froid je veux dans
mon pions vous les gens vous êtes
pratique mais nous vivions un flic est
ce que veut dire ce mot ça ne peut pas
juste faire cavalier si cela un moment
donné ce que tu veux ici tout gagne quoi
ou qui s'est complètement gagnant c'est
quand les 6 d'indécis à cavaler sur 24
c'est une bonne année autour de deux
cols et sissoko les six de suite ou si
c'est un bon ou un wok et ouais ouais
quel gâchis oui mes chers amis élèves en
train de témoigner
le vrai cauchemar pour les besoins de
cette ouverture car libourne en que ne
semble pas trop des idées de son
ouverture on permis à tous de quoi les
noirs et là il ya le fou qui va
rejoindre la taxe est finie fouache 3
quel plaisir indescriptible dans le
trois roues h à l'égard des collègues ou
trois tours à un moment donné mais bon
point quoi réussissent bien jouer quoi
du coup le cavaly b3 se retrouvent bête
et le cavalier arrive en f4 17 dame
justice d'amour le souvenir sinon
kovalev carteret tout mais ça me procure
un peu pour reculer un peu trop gourmand
il faut être plus ni quoi que c'est
surtout il faut pas être trop gourmand
banques et fo is his maintenant je pense
ok to come back est tué au tour de coupe
davis 5
le problème il mais qu' il il bouge je
connais je connais comme le sont la non
médias ce qu'il a bien bougé la echl
pareil je pense que ça reste bien sûr
gagnant j'ai peu de doute mais celui-ci
facile et il a il ne l est pas moi t'es
quoi l'armée vlad mais ils sont super
forts les gens de ce niveau c'est
impressionnant en fait
ok mais ça dépend de quoi ils sont très
bien pour ça pour comment dire pour
fight et d'aller position foutu par
exemple - la façon comment il se fait
avoir de l'ouverture je parle des ja
c'est très loin d'être impressionnant
voilà elle va sauver je suis sûr qu'ils
ont très mal joué par grichka à partir
d'un moment donné et justement à ton que
valérie si ce que tu attends prêcher
peut-être n'était pas bien trop trop
trop gourmand quattro est là elle va pas
gagner ça c'est évidemment dommage
dommage parce que +3 serait peut-être
quelque chose mais je me souviens que
il y à anna née il ya deux ans parfois
il perdait même deux telle position
contre personne mais contre carl scène
c'est pas le même humour mais pourquoi
joue syrie ce qui la met 20pts être la
perle en fait pourquoi elle joue si
risqué que sa cavale et ses six à sept
tours à huit est peut-être là c'est un
échec intermédiaires qui - lorsque pacte
et que tu cours tu joues pas tu joues
pas ça contre eux comme ça qu'on ne peut
rien n'est trop dangereux ou qui quoique
au pied de leur bêtise sur bêtise bien
sûr non mais je préfère les blancs
maintenant ok le formule ok il dit aux
gars des plus de mode au match retour à
deux tours ce 2
ok même pas
je mère très active peut-être cavalli
ces trois là pour les blancs ok ça va il
faut pas trop s'exciter
oui il est décidé de voir une position
simple les garder plus de même plus 3
aurait été plus que plus de fun ayant
bien sûr les incapables de perdre son
côté mauvais très mauvais il reste 22
minutes de trois plus semblables - pas
la bêche
d'ailleurs j'ai jamais compris pourquoi
il rejoue pas la bête les positions
n'ont pas été excellente mais des
résultats a noté qu il a changé de
partout quoi d'ailleurs peut-être mes
chers amis on est en train de témoigner
la faute
la faute stratégique de la part de
diagne
on ne change pas les chevaux qui ramène
aller victoire en changent pas comme ça
c'est bizarre bizarre qu'on me dit là
maintenant elle va faire dame de cette
fosse 5 durera six danseurs où elle est
là qui est ce que ces normes comme la
poudre mais c'est du remplissage ou
enduits de sa vente de moscou moi j'ai
beaucoup de problèmes avec quoi c'est
une autre nouveauté oui c'est vachement
compliqué non mais c'est terrifiant a
joué pour les noirs ça en blitz surtout
step et souriante parce qu'il a besoin
de s'ouvrir
il y apprend de s'ouvrir ce n'est qu'une
et adam c'est un nom peut être pénible
écoutez j'ai analysé ça a énormément
mais je vais pas vous mentir si je me
rappelle six aides en scène autour ça ok
le plus probable et matt barnes ce
moment ça se voit maintenant les noirs
doivent être très responsable parce que
il suffit de faire en courant des comme
ça
et malgré deux pions du plus c'est archi
dur de défendre non tu peux te faire
emporter non oui donc ici c'est très
très très responsable je sais pas si
yann comprendre le challenge presque
je me rappelle pas que oui je le sais
quoi non mais il comprend quand même moi
je connais oui mais toi tu un chalet
pour une partie si vous majeur n'est
perdu beaucoup par exemple
excuse moi mais je pense que ce serait
parce que le foot ou quoi là mais il est
juste mal quoi c'est juste un coup comme
tous rêvent d un rdr dans des quatre
dames je sens que wiki les chocs
violents de sa sempé pas circuler raison
d'enjeux cinq tours dans des deux
peut-être ce sens qu'il vous plaît mais
peut-être c'est pas grave mais il a
sûrement groupe dames 2 2 mais peut-être
rien de grave parce que dans ce jeu
c'est tout et il a fait un petit visage
quoi j'ai vu sur la caméra genre de
petites grimaces quoi où et me prendre
des gens font ça à l'express j'ai pas
dis que c'est le cas mais prend des gens
font ça à l'esprit devant des grimaces
bah oui c'est vrai il ya une embellie ne
peux pas le voir vlad ces cas là ce
n'est que pour l'art ce n'est que par
l'amour de fer frais il aime bien faire
des grimaces
oui ok mais c'est quelqu'un qui était
commanditaire oui c'est quelqu'un qui a
été bouleversé par le style du cospar
aux fruits et tous ceux qui ont témoigné
qu'est ce qu'on se dit prêt tout leur
ville voire
faire des grimaces qu il mettait de
guerriers en quelque sorte parce que ils
sont tous brûlés par kasparov fois
jérémy sapina mais là après des procès
cas j'aurais fait tour b 1 c'est
suicidaire dépensé 4 eme c'est agréable
mais il comme a dit et écrit madame
prend aussi ses chèques maintenant le
roi a nulle part où aller c'est horrible
quoi ils jouent cette ligne est
maintenant tous rêvent d un mais il va y
avoir des messalistes ou quoi joue ce
crime pas plus pas plus pour que 2012
mamadou cette ligne à mon niveau en fait
il comprend juste pas sous les 2
frustrant maintenant avec les des turbos
700 réfléchir à tête aux condéens
excusez moi les papilles c'est trop et
que c'était ok bien sûr les noirs sont
foutus mnm français car je vis très bien
il va faire [ __ ] en d1 et il va
revenir avec le foin f3 et ça va être
très bien quoi et n'oublions pas il a
bien appuyé en bout plus mam a
l'impression qu'il ya cinq qui ont
beaucoup couru mais parce qu'ils peuvent
tous tombés mais fais attention le papy
ne doit pas trop s'exciter ça pourrait
être dangereux pour ton coeur parce que
dans neuf catégories de football tu peux
pas faire x 23 mai dans 5 et l'air très
très sexy
j'ai dit très sexy dans sa salle si j'ai
l'impression que tu as un excès de
testostérone avec ton vocabulaire nom et
sans citer sexy oui bien sûr je pense
que c'est compréhensible idée je pense
maintenant c'est fou bouche fouet trois
oui oh oui deux fois trois fois qu'il
faut à huit roues et freins dames 3
pardon dans le froid tu veux faire
donc oui excusez moi tellement excité
qu'il a tient ça va être une autre
miniature je suppose
20h29 couvent peut-être juste fou prend
1,5
ok ce sens que les autres comme quoi
souffre de quatre bateaux qui mouillent
calcul est pourquoi voire 5 5 pouces de
jeu 4 calcul on peut quand même ne pas
gagner n'importe quelle position que
rené c'est ça son problème contre carl
scène
voici bouffort par arrêté au caire où le
cac a pris 4 but
non mais c'est ridicule ben may 14 3 ok
d'un métro a bien joué mais ici tout ce
que tu fais c'est bien joué
ok mais bout face est quand même quoi
fougeux 4 wii + 3 ok i'm a témoigné la
faute stratégique pour rien maintenant
il doit quand même
ok ok commence dès l'ouverture du café
et les viennoiseries les quatre
cavaliers ça tu sais qu'on l'a
recommandé dans notre répertoire pour
les joueurs à 1500 non j'ai pensé qu'il
va jouer une ouverture plus qu'a fait
que ça ça c'est encore jouable
damas 3 maintenant football cette
autoroute ou audio je mets tout ça manon
plus d'habitude il ya des idées avec
tours b 4 mais pas tour b6 intéressant
est beau je ne sais pas si fort moyen
intéressant le beau mais je pense que il
est fort probable que sacha analyser ça
avant le match parce qu'ils ont pourquoi
je dois expliquer ça parce que yann cet
endroit me un ami de longue date de ma
vie et si vous tapez ce tri sur la base
de données vous allez voir qu'il y avait
des milliers de parties jouées
permissivité des gens qui est une
excellente idée pour yann dans le chatt
cavaliers des deux là n'en hockey veut
dire qu'il va y avoir des 9,5 et c'est
dangereux vient des deux donne envie
quand même ça donne
est ce que il ya ne serait pas en train
de tâches et son caleçon
ce qui veut dire des tâches et son
caleçon enfin se faire pipi de sucre à
vous sachiez dessus comme tu veux quoi
et oui de nos membres
elle a fait qu'à valider d'un vieux oui
sur des f 5 buts tout à fait huit aussi
mais ce n'est pas juste une qualité il
ya n'avait rien prévu dans le chat on a
une proposition une idée pour yann qui
te prennent comme seconde ans pour cela
oui pour me prendre tout d'abord il faut
avoir mon consentement
il est vrai que j'ai 44 ans il faut ce
serait pas mal que jan 10 dans
l'interview j'ai voulu prendre vlad
mais j'ai pas osé quoi un peu comme toi
avec bellucci qu'il complément ses
droits le plus gras complément que gmail
ou de mode et de réfugiés se trouvent 4
ouais j'suis la fac ils gravent
touristes damage khadir s'est même pas
nécessaire 5.5 peut-être à mes poils
5.66 fleuve 4 gf d'amd 6 au hockey
maria c'est fini que lecavalier ans et 5
revient jamais en attaque là s'est fait
[ __ ] vous voyez donc blip blip les
ouvertures ne sont pas importants ne
sont pas importants en fait elles sont
treize ans pourtant très souvent parce
que une fois il a lâché les greenfield
ils rallieront commencer d'avoir des
problèmes avec les noirs et il a
commencé de voir des problèmes avec les
bras en posture review qu'à se rappeler
comment
je tiens il ya comment il s'appelle ya
sébastien joie qui dans le chat un truc
assez marrant dit qu'en fait pour avoir
tourné que c'est assez simple il suffit
de me demander en plus à dire que je
suis un joueur de proxénètes oui ce
criminel sébastien et point franchement
je suis bien au courant mais j'ai tout
de suite la f3 mais j'ai fait plutôt
étroit après tout jury tout est
peut-être c'est un mauvais réflexe à
tianjin et 3g 3g 3 non c'est pas
possible j'ai adoré à brigue écoutez je
dis mais pourquoi annoncer cinq sites
humoristiques
il a fallu des loups fou pour attaquer
le roi mais je pense que non mais je
pense que j'espère tour g5 et échanger
en gênant puisqu'il guillaume il veut
tripler la ville et les pièces mais ce
qui est une mauvaise technique justement
y compris parce qu'il donne la case pour
le coach kamel ouali quoi mauvaise
technique parce que maintenant ils font
un sacré technique pour gagner saveurs
d'ailleurs vaut mieux d'accord parce que
je n'oublie pas que le chronomètre c'est
bien le chronomètre c'est bien mais ce
n'est pas son style si tu veux il est
vrai une fois ci leurs fesses a
contribué l'année dernière jouée le
point du nul ne sait pas ce style
indirect
il préfère botter qui offert je vais
quand même attention à ton vocabulaire
pour moi c'est excusable haussmann
excusable pour moi aussi mais pour
d'autres raisons qu'on voit cette
torture et en touchant toutes les cases
avec ses tours là parce que il s'est
rendu compte qu'il est les photos
horribles et le foot ou en échangeant
les quais mais faut surtout pas qui
craint qu'il soit solide dans sa tête en
qui ont attaqué avec laure foot de 3,7
les noirs qui sommes attaqués à les plus
fous sur ces huit essais le principe
numéro 1 de l'éloigner du rpm qui m'a
prescrit de jeu
c'est encore de virtual au fou le plus
actif sur ces huit fois moins pas voulu
bouger surtout après tout beau et on
bosse historicisme vrai le plan assez
jolie qui l'a qu'il avait employé des
nouveaux d'ailleurs je crois que c'est
ça va être très dur à gagner ça et dont
je jure qu'il voit pire un f3 peut-être
oui mais c'est yann donc il ya quelque
chose
seyyam mam et f3 jour quelque chose ok
mais là qu'est ce qui peut vouloir ok
mais tu m'as prêché pendant des heures
pour les tours quelque chose que là
c'est ridicule
dans ce cas là où donc était à sa à son
tour de faire les photos horribles avec
son quand ella baché la glace je pense
que la dame va sur des quatre dames en
échec dans les caves y as tu regardé 4e
tour justice c'est rien ça devient
facile parce que pour un oui mais pour
justifier cette dame 6 à oui ok à chaque
fois il veut pas jouer tour je suis pas
à cause d'un mois sans que je suppose
oui je pense que c'est ça le problème
mais est ce que c'est si horrible que ça
la met à damas d'un même si c'est après
tour je crois savoir hockey a tant il
est mal un ratio trop pur donc que c'est
la dame parce que peut-être c'est une
forteresse mais l'impôt et technique
c'est peut-être la damassine cities de
la versys d'abord tu as tu sais je
n'utilise h4 est suracheté
peut-être fut même tour g1 donc je crois
très dommage car à 8 tours jusqu'à tours
hkd bien vive la halle et nature
sérieuse
certains mois quoi dans les 400 réfléchi
et au gel menace dames 1 en mai 2006 oui
ok c'est pas moi c'est complètement
gagnant pour bouffe à ok mais bouffé
tout 23
agréable les quatre plus car la ddt
donc ça va ça prend forme
tu en mets qui roule comme cela cet
anonyme dont on connaît pas le nom à il
rejoint field ok mais peut-être c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle au china daily
les voici à tous les ordres de guy
lafleur dire de quoi ces idiots et bien
sûr à cause de photos sont accrochées
faute de ces défauts de trois ans
c'est le foot
et bien sûr ce n'est que moi sont
d'aider ce fou de phobos est de 5 sur
trois échecs même ça c'est pas du tout
convaincant pour moi parce que faudel au
fond de l'eau d'un dock 044 mais bon ici
tout doit être bien ou de trois fours
on se fout de trois semaines qu'est ce
que les revenus modestes le main des 5
avec les défauts c3 forestier cédant 2 3
des 5 6 4 6 2 6 3 5 maps
ben là je sens une baisse de régime en
terme de niveau chez les deux joueurs ok
quand même plus là par doit y en avoir
moins
je dois dire que je détestais le choix
de jouer fois ci je déteste ce choix à
chaque fois qu'ils gagnent et les green
field avant il gagné avec des oeufs des
tomates
maintenant c'est sûr qu'il va pas faire
mal c'est donc j'ai pas aimé ça ok
maintenant sur l'aude et bien sûr ce
soit faux bond au soir où vivent 4 après
que cinq blessés s'y sont collé de
quatre colis des troubles et des justes
dieu t'aidera
j'aimerais jugé peut-être je dois
m'excuser de partout où je sais et le
transfert du coglais sur bois d'auch une
très grosse nation pourquoi tourbe de
quelqu'un peut m'expliquer ce que moi je
ne peux pas quoi pourquoi tours bordeaux
pourquoi pas d'un but 2 passes qui dit
que c'est pareil quand même faire
cavalier 5 et veut pouvoir doubler ses
tours ou peut-être un bon je comprends
pas quel outil intéressant oui c'est
rappeler il s'est rappelé à chaque fois
elle a gagné celle gagnée avec moi tu ok
voici réfléchis pas trop à tan tan et
peut-être du tour descartes la tête du
tour des quatre qui marche la sq et le
cavalier est quand même très soupçonnant
bellevue offert il veut que à vendre
l'autre bourg
la colle on sait que le sang qui après
tour de quatre mois qui de toute manière
je préfère les bons avec n'importe qui
et où je sais pas mais qu'il est mieux
peut-être car et j5 maintenant ah non
non non mais pas avec les tours sur
d'heure ne pas avec les communes série
ouverte
tu vas pas faire moite et surtout pas
avec plus qu'un tel que tu vois on
pourrait peut-être tour des deux tours
des cadres du coup tours 2 2 que le
cateau de katako laisse 3 alors qu'on
s'écarte à j'aime pas ce qu'elle fait je
ne pense qu'il faut il merda 5e et tour
des quatre mamans échanges cette tour
vraiment de après ça le problème
non ok dans ce cas là vaut mieux de jeu
comme au hockey typique oui voici fait
tout à tour décadente où quatre dames à
d'autres de cette tour de 8 dans vos
cinq dames aussi ces abandons qui
préfèrent 17 direct kg 3 plus
pragmatique à symbolique
j'ai rédigé trois hommes jeux d'eau
seraient 400 m mais les curieux sont
davantage des pilatus h4 et h5 ça
appartient pour cette position je vais
jamais de ma vie comprendre pourquoi est
ce qu il n'a pas fait grand écran et
camaïeu 5 et 6 où elle paraissait mais
bon tu fais pas ça tu fais jamais ça
surtout tu fais pas ça comme tu es +4
peut-être manque de lucidité aussi wlan
à la fatigue les partis qui s'enchaînent
plaide complète complete là maintenant
il est sur ma famille aux attentes ya
une idée peut-être pas mal quoique
peut-être dame proche 3 ayora tourcoing
quoique non mais derrière une dame k o
dans ce type de chose quand williams iii
je suis pas sûr du tout
c'était quoi l'aider kovalev douloureux
5 et les noirs pire du matos à leurs
mains possibles
j'arrive pas à calculer 20 tourcoing 3
après que vos livres d'auteurs cinq
tours trois acolytes quatre échecs ou
les trois mois yade en bout de chaîne et
même là c'est pas la forme parce que
dans mon nouveau arrive sur f3 après
auquel les banques peuvent pas être
mondiales n'ont qu'à les croire c'était
c'était assez dur dur de 5 à l'heureux
qu'elle est revenue angers 5 pour
prendre 5
mais ok ça valait peut-être tour des
cinq mamans qui refera des trois actes
c'est très bizarre comme la décision
parce que pour sécuriser tour de 5
c'était justement ce que le docteur a
prescrit quoi l'âge de pur qu'il ya un
devoir ou dribbler un moment donné il
est horrible d'un sit in des trucs
horribles juste
c'est chaud un hyper chaud très
intéressant je suis pas content oui oui
oui bien sûr si dans les quatre dom ses
six enfants
tipi quoique dans le cratère dans ce
système marche 5 jeux hd 7 oui un peu
toujours sacrifié en f1 alors elles se
posent les questions requis il n'a pas
de temps pour calculer tout ça donc la
proche pratiqueront de huelva pire dos
et il peut d'abord sac et peut-être si
nulle part répètent
non mais oui oui bon ok il devrait être
puni pour l'absence complète
de l'art de la proche pratique en mêlée
et leurs 5 et que les colons c'est que
le colon s'est ouverte et s'appartient
pas ici j'ai nommé la très mal joué un
très mode jeu après une telle ouverture
ok le bric pas du tout normalement il
n'y a pas de pause enfants du match
maintenant ça s'est réchauffé donc faut
maintenant montrer les eaux synchro avec
les noirs qui viendraient ce congrès
pour la fondue en fait il se passe un
truc bizarre c'est qu'il reste encore
deux minutes de 3 + 1 et les deux
joueurs sont partis
les deux joueurs sont pas sur leur
chaise et je sais pas si je pense que
chaque point comme va annuler la partie
parce que et great uk yann pense que
c'est fini en fait le 3 0 le 3 plus sain
et bon jeu mais c'est pas les boulettes
encore il reste une partie mais juste
les deux sont partis aucun d'entre eux
n'étaient assis sur sa chaise et donc la
nouvelle règle au chèque maintenant que
les joueurs avec leur consentement
mutuel pour partir les deux en même
temps
bah je sais pas quoi ils sont partis
tous les deux en fait ils devaient pas
s'il n'ya pas pause ils ont fait une
erreur quand ils ont pensé que c'est
fini mais il reste une partie de trois
minutes
en fait il ya des gens dans le chat qui
a écrit pause pause pause quoi et ils
ont dû les croire mais la personne du
staff qui est à ce point comme qui écrit
ça moi aussi je rêve que de la pause
j'ai besoin gaumont brixner le message
que ces peuples 5 et que +3 quel dommage
ok un peu de suspense va en profiter
tant les mecs pour faire un petit
partage sur sur facebook 1 on y va il
reste encore une bonne demi heure de
match en a combien qui viennent c'est
pas d'un foie gras en étant les six ans
et calque on et 630 je crois si mon truc
est bon ce qui est un bon chauffeur ce
qui est un très bon chiffre
ce qui est un des meilleurs chiffres
qu'on à 100 comment dire si c'est pas
maxime normalement on n'a pas autant de
joueurs de personne et d'ailleurs j'en
profite
on dira tout le monde qui on commentera
avec fabien et moi un peu seul le rapide
de la sinne que phil cup samedi dimanche
et lundi soir à partir de 20h sur la
chaîne twitch bitstream j'ai mis un lien
donc si vous voulez pouvoir suivre avec
nous à partir de samedi soir il y aura
gris tube qui jouera y aura vlad qui
sera sur place à saint louis
si tu as eu de visa d'ailleurs sacha a
obtenu son visa mais le problème c'est
qu'ils ont eu un doigt en cours
avant il n'y a rien dressent encore des
petits problèmes techniques mais
j'espère qu'ils ont envoyé rigaux
normalement ils vont jouer ce sera alors
à maxime vachier lagrave et sera donc on
fera ça samedi dimanche lundi
tous les soirs à 20h les gens sont très
contents d'eux des commentaires écoutez
je pensais que je suis roanne de mon
meilleur niveau je joue plus du tout
mais j'espère parfois pouvoir pour
pouvoir parfois vous éliminer ce que ce
poisson et que tu vas tu sais pas ce qui
va se passer là dans le sens où est ce
qu'ils vont quand même jouer la partie
qui devaient être joués ou est-ce que ça
va partir tout de suite sur les bullet
je sais pas je ne veux pas qu il y en a
a pris cette habitude de fumer dommage
pour lui quoi ne commencez pas à fumer
les enfants spa bien voilà tu confirmes
n'ont donc fait jamais signé à
l'amazonie ailleurs jamais très mauvais
pour la santé
très cher en plus tu sais mes grands
parents qui sont de l'ancienne
génération
en fait ils disent pas que fumer c'est
pas bien parce que c'est mauvais pour la
santé est ce que c'est beaucoup trop
cher comme après c'est dommage pour moi
qu'ils taxent plus les taxes palais
chloé les clubs comme moi je pense pas
qu'ils s'embrassent et que là tout le
monde s'arrête et en arrêtant de la
discussion
oui oui non mais c'est sûr à faire les
mêmes choses pour l'alcool mais pour les
clopes aussi le premier qui votent pour
mais pour l'alcool jeanine lecot jamais
donc est-ce que ça va vraiment ils sont
partis en bus ladlad laddh c'est parti
pour le bullet donc bon ok retenons le
souffle
bon bon bon bah oui oui comme j'ai dit
il va refaire les cas c'est ce que les
boulettes tt sur quoi tu savais pas ce
que il aimait avec eux il connaît toutes
les filles mais s'ils se souviennent des
petites taille marchande donc pour une
déchirure général donc ça c'est un petit
peu ce qu'on a vu dans la vidéo avec toi
qu'on a que j'ai mis en ligne
aujourd'hui ce matin voilà pour jouer
baissier s'élèvent déjà consacrer un peu
de temps mais ça veut dire que ok je
sais que l'évolution est bon pour les
organes heures pourquoi pour le noir -
boîte déjà je me rappelle pas de caisse
qui se passe ici est est ce qu'on veut
faire mais on peut pas je vais faire
dame c5 et échanger mais on peut pas
parce que y'a vous une partie importante
de chronique avec le noir va regarder
déjà quand même il ya nettement mieux
aux tables d'armes 3f cinq caisses
conseil a pris le parti de chronique
très important joué il ya deux ans les
meilhanais entendriez du temps vlad
malgré tout bas il a pris cette décision
de jouer ce qu'il connaît par coeur mais
il doit quand même décidé à chaque fois
qu'est ce que je joue précise marie oui
mais est ce que c'est que ça je pense
que à l'aider dans ses 3 ou heureusement
il faut ce 5e tir au but de ktm faute
d'accord ok maintenant je suppose poule
5 un grand roque peut-être ok il a
égalisé sûrement malgré la structure de
pions parce que les blancs à ont du mal
à finir le développement je sais je suis
pas 100 % sur caen - quoique ok les
décès cure il voit pas jouer il veut
quoi je veux tour ho8ot maintenant il se
passe quoi là surtout rassure vite
agresso 5,6 à ce qu il veut faire pas
surtout ma chemise ou jeu qu'à 3
le fourreau sur m6 est mauvais il faut
oui absolument aucun acte iv aussi vite
que possible
ce qu' il est à prendre des français
nous vous faire le coup sûr des quatre
excellents les structures n'est toujours
pas excellente moyenne inquiets mais
beaucoup autour de nos enfants tout en
nous à tour à tour deux tours de toute
urgence un super indirects soit là ok
les noirs sont bio mais hyper dur goût
gagné sauf ok l'aider et bien sûr de
transport pourquoi roissy 6 il fallait
faire un investissement pour aller vers
des quatre tours de 3 à 5 photos
ok si tu sais pas comment gagner mais ok
pourquoi faire nul quand on peut faire
la montre non d'abord fait la moindre
est après faut ni à qui la préfèrent la
la mais qu'est ce que t'es vieux donc
pratique c'est un vieux papy quand papy
fait de la résistance
tu as vu ce que tu connais oui un papy
comment j'arrive pas d'où il faut que tu
te reconnais que ça c'est déconnecté
faut que tu reviennes il faut que tu
fasses un refresh
c'est chez ce point comme qui veut te
punir en mangerait plus là il faut que
tu te reconnais que là tout bêtement
africa24 justice
le dernier des lieux jeu et vous voyez
donc oui quand les ce2 au cinquième
c'est une souveraineté rares ok on voit
assez clairement que les stratégies de
riches ou comme les auteurs jouent plus
rapide
il joue pour faire ma htwe mais je
prends vraiment beaucoup plus vite pour
le moment gratuit qui joue très vite
aussi
elle tend l'autre joue plus vite tu
joues pour faire maths parce que
normalement c'est pas une bonne
technique de jouer vite comme le témoin
tout simplement parce que chaque coup
est beaucoup plus restreint de fabrique
d'habitude mais là il est un petit peu
mieux non avec les blancs mon problème
c'est qu'ils ont je suis toujours
mauvais pour évoluer les pousses de les
françaises parce que je pour faire
toujours les bois j'ai le même problème
que toi mais là j'aimerais village envie
de faire tourner trois cavaliers g5y est
bouffé tour h3 et mater sur la colonnade
bêtement en fait exactement les mots
prononcés mais souvent ça marche pas du
tout et souvent c'est ça c'est pas du
tout la chanson de grand corps malade ce
cauchemar pas du tout dans mon sac j'ai
ma place a pris ses marques
une pression que c'est juste moi poids
j'ai l'impression ce juste moi même il
défend jan
mais bon qui gagnent ils aimaient avec
les françaises aussi dont golan à la 7e
place comme au salaire de le faire' nahd
et les secours qui via un + 3/5 et +3 et
y restent plus 4 et reste 24 minutes à
jouer
ok la poigne où l'alors la
pointe-du-moulin qui retourne en
l'espagnol yann qui s'était fait
éliminer l'année dernière au premier
tour par cars jaeckin et il avait
commencé la série de 5 + 1 qu'il avait
perdu 9 à un holà
t'imagines ça qui a perdu 1,9 en a pas
ils étaient menés 9 a en tout cas je
sais plus c'était le 5 + 1 ou quoi mais
il y avait neuf un moment donné dans le
match et j'ai vu juste pour te dire que
carey yakine sera très dangereux parce
qu'il avait juste écrasé jan non je sais
de quoi ça parle
bon bon bon les deux joueurs soient
c'est quoi ce coup de force
ces archives des arts en tant qu une
réflexion c'est très mal joué c'est les
réflexes que moi j'ai quand je suis pas
en forme
c'est assez idiot je le dis parce que à
vire que de télé avec une telle marge
des pions il est impossible que le noir
ne sont pas mieux
ok f4 mais persiste à nice 2-0 six f4
sur le côté moitié de retraite du
serveur qu'est ce qu'on veut dire
soupçonnant que peut-être permis aux
bleus d'égaliser vêtements f6 que
l'effroi des quatre français après deux
des quatre peut-être
et voilà il a permis à l'auteur
d'égaliser ce qui a été bien de vous
être c4 mon nom est ok la masse égale
les bombes peuvent devenir mieux mais si
le noir fonds réa maintenant il faut
faire gaffe au noir oui n'est pas
permettre que les trois quarts des
quatre manches à dire ils affirment être
canonisé 4 mais c'est pas grave si je
vais expliquer de telles choses de telle
chose qui choque comprendre mille fois
mieux que moi ok tours 2 500 bons coups
soixante mille et une histoires
sauf que les noirs doivent faire gaffe
aux cd de maths avec le courrier sur jeu
5 qui marque énormément ne sont pas
réalisables
ok ça s'échange petit peu prendre un cas
très haut et le voir faire tourner au
heat
ça c'est sûr même pas tous très que tous
ces quatre mois qu'ils étaient trop à -2
si tu veux donc hélas a affirmé ok voici
bougez bougez les pièces haïtien il fait
pas ça est ce qu'il y ferait pas ça
parce que c'est un compatriote
non non non c'est juste elle pense que
c'est un peu moi ça
inquiet mais la dernière fois où yahoo
là le dernier 2 le jeu quand il jouait
contre les français il n'a pas pensé que
c'était malsain
je connais cette petite ligne en fait
c'est l'une des bombes ligne contre
seconde vie avec les bois y en a plein
qui sont bien à pour les bois celle où
bill mais c'est quoi ce système est une
chose chez coca cola beau des quatre
éditions bamboo ce serait le problème du
yen très souvent le jeu plus osées chez
ne sait plus comment s'appelle son jours
à quai les joues et à deux ados
tu veux dire que là ils jouent à dota 2
plutôt présent cette partie il joue
plutôt d'autres tâches 0 que boston a
news
quoique on m'aurait dit moore top mais
c'est pas ça c'est les échecs ou quoi
la mefou c5 des quatre fois le jeu
j'avoue son cavalier berchem et tu
menaces tu vas peut-être menacé un
moment donné quand même cavalli premier
set malgré le cavalier dévide genre sur
m6 après si tu veux que vous avez
remboursé à 100 mais est ce que ça
marche encore trois points f7 pour
bouger n'importe qui les quatre grilles
et encaisse lecavalier après attaque à 4
3 2 1
peut-être bien est la plus belle oui
bien sûr ben ali rêve ou quoi
moi j'aurais pb à padoue buy out ou ce
que n'est pas un bon signe ça se
comprendre les deux sens très fatigué ok
mais c'est pas si grave fouet cas
peut-être et j'aime pas faux ce doute du
tout faux h3 pour défendre le pitch de
douai pour bouger
6 pouces 12,7 une mauvaise technique à
eelv you stopper le cavalier excusez moi
sinon pourquoi excuse moi ok bien sûr
c'est complètement derrière attend ait
là quoi il a deux pions de plus
ouais deux points de plus et là en foot
est comme les surfaces est d'ailleurs
parfois cette c5 c'était le seul et
d'aimer d'être touré fin à noël il
aurait pu bien bouffer le plus mal
élevés offerts aux arches de roues à
trois requêtes
vous savez dans les finales selon chérif
qui est les compagnies c'est ça la
technique c'est en anglais tout livre de
poésie sont d'accord montella position
mais à pouvoir à pouvoir dans le film
animèrent up pasqua je n'ai pas vu ce
film animé vlad et parmi les films
animés les plus géniales les plus
juniors et les techniques cette
répétition là c'était marrant d'ailleurs
gamme elle a toutefois paru le 5 mai il
a pas raison parce qu'ils jouent jamais
ok - 5 ces faits dramatiques
c'est dramatique pour une fois sur un
podium le roller à au pardon pardon j'ai
pensé que ces gars qui jouent les c'est
à dire non c'est sacha cgri chaque homme
tu l'appelles intéressant mais c'est
quoi ce décollé de 4 kg 4 c'est
incroyable vous donnez pas caennais
terre de tes trucs vasif eurostar
apprend oui les bonnes manières et m
daté de il ya cinq siècles belle et
studieux mais attendez ce qui va pas
voir
donc je suis quoi boum
que voler des six tours d'où ils
suffisants et qui se voit faire mieux je
suppose comme en double il cavale et ses
huit nuits j'ai pas de manière c'est pas
de façon si moi je peux faire le bouffer
notre four ou halal halo wars
quand j'ai dit ce que je dis je vais au
cours des quatre heures avec le détour
bout il faut booster
ok là ça va être dur quand tu vas mettre
la langue et ours et de satyam tourbeux
quatre tours à katara tour bout de
rocher
ça c'est bizarre quand même parce que
maintenant ce sont les banques qui sont
encore mieux
ok f st croix rouge cet art est fou de
faire ces quatre noms paroisse des
saints qui ça valait pas la peine pour
mourir web et les noirs ne sont pas
moins bien c'est pas la peine que le
voyez vous j'ai pas vu roi des 5
les deux se respecte énormément oh là là
mais du coup la pendule tourne là dans
chaque partie pas perdus par grytsak
meilleure variante c'est pas les
meilleurs voeux rien pour les bois ça ça
va par contre - 0 qu'est ce qu'il ya vu
obtenir il veut obtenir une position à
la française qu'il toujours évident tout
moins serrés sans bulles énormément à la
française avec 5 ou gris choucas énormes
sommes énormément d'expérience aussi
d'ailleurs pour qu'ils se récupère dans
le match 2 5 au lieu de petit roux était
plus intéressant g5 le petit rock pour
les noirs voici tu perds dommage oui
pour envoyer mais bon normalement c'est
engendre
position will rock you lynne ley banking
bébé qu'elle connaîtra peut-être là
cavalier g5 quand même est d'ailleurs la
dernière faute stratégique a provoqué
l'un peut abandonner d'air après fou et
4 dames 1 3 we want dance 2 3 les noirs
sont juste fou tu m'offres 14 ou quoi
une affaire d'âme trois franchises ladd
et fiefs cathares section c'est une
prophylactique compter réussi ces
machins adam ou trois ans mais est ce
que je dis que je vais faire fois ci
c'est prendrai ma tête
écoute météo
je suis jaloux tu vois ça tout de suite
le cavalier 5 maintenant les cavaliers 4
et bouffage 6 quoi peut-être flot
sanguin il est possible âgés de 3 2 me 6
1 qui dirait qu'il prend des quatre
peut-être ça part en couilles mais ça
part en couille complètement
il a perdu le contrôle de la ddt
complètement vrai est ce trop excité
comme un wiki mais ça se comprend c'est
elle utile totale pour y aller et puis
ok c'était assez ridicule non mais c'est
trop écrit et et moi maintenant je
suppose qu'en l'e3 n'est pas moi non
plus il veut mettre la dame en d4 et le
cavalier endéans les réflexes grande
réflexion car il faut absolument ne pas
perdre cette partie tient à mal accepté
très beau jeu pas mal la part de yann
vlad c'est pas fini si on gagne c'est là
tout est encore possible
ok il veut jouer dans le jeu 3 et comme
je crois maintenant ok c'est assez
solide où il une bonne et dé maintenance
et de je bosse accueilli 6,6 non non non
c'est pas une case qui appartiennent à
la tour et c'était quoi l'aider après
coluche il ya des trucs avec tour fn où
ça marche pas du tout non ça marche pas
c'est justin et changements requis et
c'est le titre apple c'est le type de
panier et le web part avoir du moins
pour sauver saab reçoivent que souvent
c'est le thème d'anglais et dan dan b3
bien y avait dans des trois rois je suis
d'un mach iii y rentrer dans la finale
qui était gagnante je pense auprès des
secours
vas-y répète jusqu'à la fin des temps
j'ai froid j'ai trois mais inquiet il va
pas jouer le temps une nouvelle fois on
se moquait new le quoi pourquoi
à moi j'ai trois dents mais pourquoi il
n'a pas essayé de moi je trouve je sais
pas moi qui ai plus de virtuoses des
instances religion voire deux parties
avec les médias médusé il reste plus que
12 minutes normalement cinq parties ça
va mais il aurait pu tuer le match avec
la pendule s'il avait ayant peut-être
surtout ce qui moi qui l'ont critiqué
l'année dernière contre max doit
vraiment voix pour dire qu il faut pas
du tout ça moi j'aurais fait
personnellement moi aussi c'est juste
que c'est les règles c'est comme ça
enfin moi je considère que si c'est dans
les règles que faire quoi
problème c'est que les autres vont faire
contre toi un jour manquer donc
peut-être revenons mot sur la position
non mais là ça va les flaveurs hockey à
bouaye après ces quatre maintenant non
après c'est beau c'est 4 je pense les
noirs les points menace les bonnes
risque d'être moins bien objectivement
l'élan sont moins bien non après tout
c'est quoi le coin pour le bo
ben amos est tout autant de suite et les
listes noires vouées fille de feu dame
ou trois mâles faut éviter à ma droite
et fort il veut gagner sa dame où il va
pas gagner sa grande parce que les noirs
comme les trois étaient beaucoup plus
fort avec kaboul quand les vitraux elle
aurait pu sceller en grenat vague en
avantage numérique le guen et si jamais
nulle c'est bien quoi non les patrice en
feutre cynique au sol et cinq sur les
cloisons pib 3 pts et non sur moi il
veut libérer la casse des 5 pour le fou
peut-être un peu trop fins non ok allez
je pense que tu devrais te tire deux
tours 2-3 être trop tentant comme j'aime
son que yani calcul plus rien en fait 5
oui oui ça ressemble à une domination
s'il a faim s'ils vont le joug des
chèques normal
guichou couru domine complètement dans
sept derniers dix parties - williams et
bat avec ses enfants
maintenant il est écoeuré là il refait
des grimaces kayhan tank et un maillot
parce que parfois il faut pas oublier
que tu joue aux échecs au kiné c'est la
fin du mois et plus si c'est le reste
c'est une première aide agréable avec
quoi je félicite nous tous
sasha jolie fille si les filets c'était
plus tard comment tu vas le féliciter
clap oui 4 4 mais ça en doute sinon
c'est une ligne très jouable pour les
noirs mach 4 c'est un tueur relate
comment tu vas féliciter sa chasse en a
que je peux t'assurer mais c'est pas
juste ton que de la voie que tu as prise
pouvait donner quelques doutes quoi ça
veut dire je sais pas ça va regarder
qu'il interprète comme tu veux ok ah oui
parce qu'il y avait la partie il y avait
le parti de ben je vais donner même réel
talent qui a été ramené que le média
roumain je pense que ça va ça laisse les
plus en fait
maintenant ils sont sur la terre pas
kuan yew mais c'était plus ou moins faim
vous voyez donc en fait là comment
s'appelle la culture de sacha et d'aller
perturber beaucoup elle est plus grande
quand même parce que n'importe qui et
l'ouverture choisi gagnent partout les
moins bien heureux tout le temps il ya
des fils il ya des trucs accueilli ces
cinq noms qui peut rodez
oui mais plus maintenant peut-être ceux
qui disent que l'ouverture n'est pas
importante dans le blitz et peut-être
savent pas qu est-ce que c'est l'oubli
ce du plus haut niveau possible
bien sûr les importants ah tiens tourner
quand les ce sans coût d'embauché
peut-être mc5 non fallait se sent que
trop tentant on le voit plus rien
ouais c'est 5 points connaissant gagnait
juste parce que le cavaliere s'était
éprise ce sens qu aussi bien à fois ci
ça ok bah oui c'est ça en fait ces cinq
ans la boucherie total
tu sais qu'il ya aussi de l'argent qui
en jeu wlan
tu sais que ben yahia il ya de l'argent
qui est en jeu avec le pourcentage
je soigne à 2000 dollars en jeu mille
dollars pour le vainqueur et 1000 $ qui
se partagent pourcentage de victoires
donc avec chaque parti gagne peut-être
50 ou quelque chose comme ça ce que
peut-être pas beaucoup pour eux et quand
même agréable on est beaucoup pour toi
quoi ah ouais ok x 5 dans cette position
c'est l'un des co existence
c'est tout ce que je peux dire mais
c'est l'âme de coûts existe un domaine
que voler ses 6 mais pourquoi a great ue
qui s'entête encore jouer des trucs
hyper théorique et tout alors qu'il a
gagné le match
bah écoute bientôt elle va jouer saint
louis fait ils s'entraînent ils
s'entraînent déjà cqr dépit peut-être
revoir mes notes déjà pour tout le monde
qu'il va gagner
là il est juste en train de se faire la
main quoi est ce que ça te rassure pour
le toit de saint-louis son niveau ce
soir j'ai pas trop aimé les premières
parties mais lui reste avant ça ferait
une heure déjà que j'aime bien parce que
c'est quand même une belle victoire face
à yann qui m'est cher ami c'est
peut-être important de le dire qu'à
moins que je suis particulièrement
content de cette victoire convaincante
ce soir parce que je préfère beaucoup
plus quand même l'effet nocif hirschi
qui en degré choc par rapport à la
philosophie de
deux gars c'était une rencontre de style
entre un joueur pratique
bien que tous les défauts et tuo sacha
oublie jamais quelque chose chez et j'ai
l'impression que parfois c'est le
problème de yann et excusez moi pour
parler pour sortir des mots comme ça non
est ce que c'est les échecs du haut
niveau ça m'inquiète plus ou moins dridi
que vous lèverez dirais donc c'est
normal que c'est punir plus sets déjà et
plus et le plus probablement vont être
punis boualem et vlad si mentalement
c'est très difficile à jouer ces matchs
vraiment quand tu craques c'est
difficile
moi qui joue des trucs qui ressemble un
peu plus c'est parce que je veux dire
c'est pas ça ce que je vais dire ce que
je vais dire ce que quand tu joues que
qiu que tu nous fais pas juste bouger
les pièces ouais mais il a il a surtout
fait ça dans la dernière phase du match
ils haïssent il a craqué à un moment
donné vlad on vous connaissait cette
insulte c'est insultes en anglais good
push oui pousseurs de bois en français
ça existe c'est justement ce que fait
depuis un moment
yahmed ailleurs il voit gagner cette
partie avec cette prochaine
non mais blague ce que je veux dire
c'est que ce format est assez spécial g
jour un truc qui ressemble ils ont à peu
près le même format pour un tour et qui
s'appelle les arénas et je peux te dire
qu'après une heure et demie deux parties
qui s'enchaînent comme ça à un moment
donné tu as le cerveau qui tu peux
craquer quoi mentalement d'ailleurs très
intéressant comme le chenal d'ailleurs
pas si simple à gagner non parce que à
vrai dire je suis même pas sûr que ça
grince
oui parce que et pourquoi est-ce que ça
gagne et a presque pas de moitot s'il
est ok au sauna côté qu il est très
facile de jouer avec les noirs c'est pas
à moi ma tête il fallait changer les
dames ouvert cinq bien sûr une fois le
jeu colère ça coule de dourges
ok la fatigue ce sens oui les bains dans
mes blagues c'est difficile
franchement c'est difficile ah oui non
l'industrie
il faut être objectif la dia trois
heures de jeu le match est
mathématiquement gagner pour sacha et
c'est difficile pour les deux joueurs de
rester à 100% surtout pour yann il y
perd le match c'est difficile
ah ouais mais d'ailleurs décidé quelque
part un 3-3 ouais ouais
le match a été décidé
qui marchent maintenant au tour de 4 ou
6 6 euros au fils d'un bowie tourer 7 et
mati re de marche pas ok désolé non le
match s'est décidé à un moment donné
quand grille tout cas fait le break la
qui les passe à +2 et c'est là que ça
s'est enchaîné pour yann c'était serré
serré serré à un moment donné gris tout
cas gagné une partie importante dans
l'espagnol d'ailleurs en fait quand ils
allaient checker ses nattes et qu'il a
trouvé les bagages des mois que se
décider quand elle était aller checker
saba en fait c'est ça qui a changé la
dynamique du match l'espagnol a commencé
à fonctionner avec les noirs yann s'est
mis à changer d'ouverture et chez c'est
un peu ce qu'on disait
du coup avec le service y en a eu du mal
à gagner et yann oui c'était un cours
presque galles ou égal au niveau du
secours peut-être plus an pour pour glee
show le mois jeudi céder comme il y en a
décidé de la mairie c'est ce que
j'allais dire et après on sait pas
pourquoi il a lâché nature le long des
hashed très mauvais combat à l'entracte
bien sûr quand les bras on a un fou sur
georges et 6 passes
oui bon bloquer les cases blanches est
prévu ça comme un instinct quoi pour un
gramme à tort d'ailleurs c'est toi qui
m'a pris je savais pas chez tous parce
que tout le monde le sert de réseau et
les maintenant il va faire ceci à temps
et surtout f3 cet abandon
non c'est plus les échecs et yann qui
est un peu écoeuré sur sa chaise
ok c'est la dernière partie jupe 11 la
halle safire par une écossaise même pas
enfin non bis écossais oui les théories
maintenant c'est fou je quatre fous du
foot 4 que l'espoir aux trois fours
froide dans ces quatre dames dos dames
aux deux anneaux
adam de 3,2 dans votre offre aussi ce
beau oui donc ces quatre d'entre eux
trois ces les théories incroyable donc
évidemment prendrait quatre familles où
il faut dos c'est ok c'est les petites
lignes du coffre mais à ce niveau là en
fait les lignes de café ça marche plus
du tout quoi le problème c'est crade et
les voiliers sais qui sur ces niveaux
bolelli de café le connaissons il vient
de gagner avec eux une mise de pions du
moine avec de faux comptes heures de
cavale il répète le témoin d'ailleurs
j'ai jamais compris pourquoi elle a mis
son cavalier sur recettes pourquoi pas
si c'est parce qu'ils accueillent des
saints qui à tour b 5
oui et comme d'hab y'a en chair de des
petites filles est jeune et qu'on la dit
moi j'ai quelque chose auquel il va
faire cavani va faire cavaler b4 à l'anc
et vikash peut pas assez cru autour des
8 et machin 28 me donne combien de
pourcentage de chance contre kamski
demain bah ça dépend si tu vois trouver
comment jouer contre oui j'ai aucune
idée comment je vais contrat du site
chaux comme des beats you de ça va être
très problématique et joue assez rapide
et très très très pratique le froid donc
il faut que tu sais qu'il faut que tu
saches trouble et j'essaierai mais le
problème c'est que je jouais système de
londres et j'ai pas grande confiance
quoi j'ai pas le temps de préparer
quelque chose pour ça
6 jeux à 4 non mais j'ai pas envie du le
cas du jeu très mal maintenant match où
tu joues pas wonder compteur ce wiki
comme quoi le plus grand spécialiste
mais au contraire un général au caire
symbole du mouvement aux échecs mais
évoqué la fatigue rinsch critique voix
écoutée je m'en excuse des excuses ce
que je dis je comprends non mais c'est
vraiment vraiment bien croquer tour à
sept à six marches pour à tour a ajouté
coville sa mère jean que c'est comme un
tournoi double
tu fais du tournoi de blitz way était
déjà fatigué quand il ya dix rondes dans
la journée oui ok là temps joue pas
distant joue 25 et tu joues pas en 7h tu
joues en trois arrêts l'armée c'est
épuisant pas de race est qu elle est de
le stalingrad à thiembronne ça colle et
de witt a été quand même se faire
caillasser 5 et b3 quale c'est d'aller
encaissé chasser le fou ans qui sait le
pion ne tue pas non mais là vous êtes se
faire mater avec food et de là quand
même
[Musique]
non mais c'est ridicule là ce qu'il a
fait mais bon c'est pas trop stalingrad
là c'est la bérézina non plus tôt hk toi
par contre est bizarre peut-être qatar
étaient tous les projets communs non
mais v'là d'échappée du roi ça ressemble
plutôt à la bérézina exactement dire
exactement
je pense qu'on a vu quelque chose comme
ça avec le fou sur ce set le pion passé
il a fait n'importe quoi est fait tout à
mes ok vlad c'est pas mal pour yann d'en
gagner une
quand même faut être compatissant
entreprendre et c'était c'est pas trop
mon truc de tête composé non mais ok il
a gagné le match
hays continue à jouer quand même gaffe
ils s'en foutent j'ai une patrie de plus
une autre rupture aubry 6 qui va
terminer comme le française il faut être
un beauf et damas quatre l'amérique et
50 d'en rater ça non mais même moi je
connais quoi c'est la dernière ou quoi
non ça compte pas c'est ça compte pour
rien en fait
ils ont juste rejouer mais c'est une
partie comme semblable il ya le nec du
staff de tchatche.com à ils ont décidé
de rejouer une partie n'ont pas compris
que c'était fini quoi mais la partie
qu'on ne peut rien non pour courtois
bobcat
pepper du cavalier s'éprend des caf a
gps ils font nulle quoi pas asus ça
compte pour rien en fait dan de 302
alors là tu peux nous faire un petit
commentaire pour le prochain match
contre probablement car yakine à mensah
et puis à ok mais c'est terminé en fait
non je veux quand même que se termine
est terminée non mais c'est officiel en
fait ils viennent d'écrire qui peuvent
jouer autant qu'ils veulent encore mais
juste les machines que quand même je
veux tout dire ce qu'il faut je veux
juste quand même voir comment mais ça
compte pour rien on est d'accord c'est
moi qui aie ça de toute manière c'est
fini il ya 20 millions de gens
la mégère qu'il y avait un petit enjeu
encore et c'est faisait le score final
là c'est cette partie contrat pour rien
ok je tiens à souligner quand même que
ce qu'ils sachent à ce que sur f2 il ya
tous ceux ci soient là c'est possible ce
qu'il a oublié que une fois le cavalier
sur f en posture de deux plus sûrs d'eux
c'est ça devient possible
d'un côté les noirs sont améliorées y
aura structure en créant le pion passer
de l'autre côté les bois ont obtenu d'un
échange de gazouillis sur des cas très
jeune mais tout ça sert c'est trop
facile de juger stratégiquement parce
qu'à chaque fois il faut vérifier
premier hyper juste un pion quoi
surprend ses six marches pas écrit
processus auquel doit perdre c'est bien
dieu si tu vois plus que google tu
gagnes le ps dans un couvent au mieux
que ça mais c'est tellement difficile
il a probablement vu une seconde après
en fait mais juste ça enchaîne tellement
l'écoutons peu plus un moment donné bien
sûr il a vu une seconde on peut plus
après un week end
c'est bien que ça s'arrête maintenant
parce qu'il aurait pu se faire remonter
au quai il continue quoi donc et ils ont
arrêté le truc le staff a arrêté le truc
de force quoi 11 et demi
dix sept et demi le score officiel
rosine plus s'ils souhaitent donc même
la partie précédente n'est ce pas
compter non avec la participation sera
en effet plus cinq mais sait plus si
c'est parce que ok donc bon c'est fini
je félicite vous mois - et sasha donc
donc qu'est-ce qu'il nous faut encore
dire qu'ils viennent ben pour le
prochain match probablement face à notre
ami car yakine parce que j'imagine qu'il
va se qualifier je sais plus contre qui
joue car yakine mais il a un premier
tour pas très difficile peut-être contre
duda mais je donne aucune chance à duda
6 et houda web que chanceux j'ai pas une
grand chose à dire pour l'instant déjà
ceux qui ont regardé un auteur premier
vidéo publiée il ya deux jours savent
que j'ai un très haut estime de 2 sur
karine en blitz ça je n'ai rien à
prouver dans l'oubli tire sur moi dans
le top-35 où je pas quoi au monde en
tant que le joueur double histoire fois
champion du monde c'est tout dire donc
je pense que beaucoup va dépendre de
l'ouverture russie et qui est favori
d'après toi n'ont pour l'instant pas de
favori parce que je sais qu'ils auraient
keane va prendre ça beaucoup plus
sérieusement qui aurait pu mener chi chi
chi vignes où les mains vides au niveau
de l'urgence les mots vides donc
peut-être qu'avec une favori quand même
là dessus nous lâche une info non non je
n'ai pas dit non je peux pas le dire
nous sommes pour l'instant je donne 50
et puis en fait pendant les premières
parties à va beaucoup comprendre de juin
mais
je vous rappelle aujourd'hui longs mois
a été décidée drame millions
mais comment une question peut on dire
maintenant si on ne sait pas nice que
l'intrus par un escalier te préparer
parce que ni l'un ni l'autre n'ont rien
préparé j'ai une autre question du coût
est ce que tu penses que cette
compétition le speech s est importante
voire très importante dans le calendrier
des joueurs comme grid choc car yakine
est ce que c'est un titre qui est quand
même important à gagner ou est ce que
c'est juste une compétition genre semi
amicale sur internet ok pour l'âme c'est
très important pour les médias je passe
de kerry king parce que comme il gagne
pas de tournoi - il est pour un des
sponsors à qui il doit montrer des
résultats non pour ceux qui le tournoi
que je joue bien il utilise en tant que
possibilité de montrer regarder les
connu comme un problème pour celui qui a
une dizaine de sponsors qui ont été
montés toujours pas de résultats
à courir pour greffiers ou que et là oh
quand il n'a pas de ce genre de problème
mais pour risquer vitalbo risque
important c'est que idéologiquement il
est lent doux noms qui viennent
idéologiquement et l'élan de blues
brothers
oui donc et bien sûr pour lui même si
c'est aussi pas aussi bien doté que les
hôtels compétition d'élite
il est vital pour lui de soutenir la
compétition courageuse en blitz qui qui
réunit les meilleurs joueurs du monde
c'est un tournant important pour les
deux joueurs donc ce sera un match à
enjeu à gros enjeu oui mais je tiens à
dire à tous ceux qui pensent que querrey
qui n'atteint favori que je le pense pas
et je pense que grichka assez surpris
d'un ferry avant déjà elle ceux qui
pensent que gray choc n'est pas si bien
que ça je vous invite d'eau donc compter
combien de fois il a gagné carson avec
les bois ou avec les noirs dans les
compétitions officielles
ok et face à la caméra
est-ce que maka est favori face à gries
juke
si jamais ça va jusqu'en finale là je
pense je pense qu'on peut le dire
donc d'après toi naka est quand même en
l'absence de gamsen le favori de la
compétition
le problème c'est que le problème de 400
et le problème de nomura
ok pas dans le match l'année dernière le
match personne
guichou mais en général le prix le plus
grand problème contre ces deux là c'est
que tu dois essayer de voir un écart
aussi grand que sa poésie l'arnacoeur
positif avant de l'éboulis parce que
d'aller bullet hell son concours
intraitable ok mon village je pense
qu'il est temps de bien sûr c'est sacré
et des grillades et des murs panique de
panique oui quand tu affrontes quelqu'un
aussi aussi cauchemardesque
je comprends la section du let est
difficile va je pense qu'il est temps de
laisser nos nos amis se reposait je mets
un lien vers les chaînes switch et
youtube pour nous suivre dans le futur
et à tous une excellente pour voir aussi
vite que possible et bientôt bonne
soirée tout le monde
ciao ciao la drogue